ah ja der titel ist programm leute ich bin nicht sonderlich wach der go wizard für zwei
monate eigentlich für den zapp bist du ein go wizard weil du go programmierst oder bist du
ein go wizard weil du weiss nicht sonderlich schnell bist oder was ist der hintergrund leute
ich bin echt voll im arsch ich habe gedacht komm ich habe jetzt so den nice stream streak quasi
nee einfach so war ich auch ja aber deswegen bin ich nicht kaputt das kann ich heute nicht
abreißen lassen ich mache jetzt noch mal an wegen go ok jetzt gehts aber rund hier
ich habe sogar vorhin ein video aufgenommen und zwar aber es hat mir nicht so hundertprozentig
gefallen vielleicht können vielleicht gucken wir uns das nachher an so als preview auf das was ich
was ich morgen hoch lade aber ich habe da noch ein paar sachen geändert an dem was ich aufnehmen
will heißt es werde ich in der art und weise nicht hochladen morgen zu diablo immortal ich
habe glücklicherweise jemand gefunden der mir ein bisschen high high level gameplay aufgenommen
hat dass ich den graben nicht weiter spielen muss weil ich habe so keinen bock drauf auf
dieses game ich hätte jetzt halt für ein bisschen bisschen gameplay footage gespielt
ja aber dass das weiß nicht ich muss mich da richtig überwinden den graben überhaupt
anzumachen so ein pay to win shit es ist ja noch nicht mal pay to win leute ist ja was
viel schlimmer ist es ist pay to try to win also nee oder pay to try to progress ist es
also im endeffekt hast du trotzdem dass du pays noch ultra krassen rng
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ist das dieses pixel game was vor zwei drei wochen alle alle
gespielt haben ich bin nicht sicher es gab doch so ein pixel game was alle gespielt haben
vor zwei drei wochen geht es mir dann auch ein video hochklaren ja wahrscheinlich sagen
sie was ähnliches ja aber ich werde ich werde morgen auch noch eins hochladen dann ich nehme
das aber noch mal neu auf ich muss das noch mal neu aufnehmen das hat mir nicht so gelassen
sich so ganz gefallen ich habe ein paar sachen vergessen zu sagen ja ich habe zum beispiel
nicht gesagt dass ich dass mir schon klar ist dass mobile games gerade welche die nix
kosten sich ja schon irgendwie finanzieren müssen aber der unterschied ist zu finanzieren
und diablo immortal ist diablo immortal macht diese monetisierung nicht primär um sich
einfach nur zu finanzieren sondern die machen quasi wie er ist schön whale fishing und
das eigentliche problem ist dabei dass wenn du dein spiel nicht als spiel aufbaust sondern
als cash shop dass dann halt von dem eigentlichen spiel was die leute ja zumindest mit dem diablo
titel erwarten weil man steht ja im titel halt total bis zur unkenntlichkeit verhunst
hast ja ja genau das ist ja gerade der witz man kann auch nicht mal sagen das sage ich
in dem video auch man kann auch nicht mal sagen dass die nix aufbauen kann man kann
auch nicht mal sagen das spiel ist pay to progress oder pay to win es ist pay to win
ja aber dann mit rng as fuck also es ist quasi wie wenn ich diablo ball runs mache in diablo
2 nur dass ich dafür bezahle vor jenem ball run so ja ich muss quasi eintritt bezahlen
dass ich im ball run machen kann in diablo 2 so ungefähr ist das und selbst mehr die
leute haben ausgerechnet dass du zehntausende euro ausgeben musst wenn du mit dem aktuellen
pay to win modell wirklich eine also mehr als mehr chance als dass du keine chance
hast top gear zu kriegen das ist komplett für den arsch
walle sagt boah ich als admin hatte heute eine besprechung mit dem management ja das
an sich ist schon immer richtig pains champ ja gut das ist ja normal die erzählen dir
immer das einzige was du dann sagen kannst ist ja das geht sicherlich noch früher aber
die nachteile sind dann halt die nachteile sagen was weiß ich ist nicht richtig getestet
wir wissen nicht ob es funktioniert wir wissen nicht ob es die last aushält wir wissen nicht
wie stabil das läuft ja wir können das gerne ins protokoll schreiben und wenn das management
quasi die riesigen tragen möchte ist das ja kein problem aber wichtig ist den kram
ins protokoll zu schreiben und wenn dann sich ja nachher einer beschwert du hättest nichts
gesagt das sagst du da guck her ich hab's gesagt es ist euer problem vielleicht solltet
ihr mal eure entscheidungen überdenken aber letztendlich kannst du ja auch du kannst
ja nicht wirklich viel dagegen machen außer sagen du findest nicht gut das hat die und
die probleme und wenn dann wirklich irgendjemand so im übrigen management entscheidet ja
ist mir egal wir schmeißen das jetzt einfach auf die server auf gut glück was sie eigentlich
normalerweise nicht machen weil sie auch nicht blöd dann haben sie halt pech das ist ja auch
so eine sache die mich bei uns immer ein bisschen aufregt wo ich mich auch schon an einigen
stellen ja das sagen die das sagen die denen sind die nachteile nicht egal das ist ja das
wo ich mich bei uns auch schon an einigen stellen unbeliebt gemacht habe weil ich das
halt nachträglich gesagt habe ich sagte das haben wir besprochen wir haben gesagt was
die probleme sind die probleme sind eingetreten und man hat sich explizit dafür entschieden
das zu machen und das kommt nicht gut an im prinzip ist es wahrscheinlich auch für die
karriere nicht förderlich wenn man wenn man die leute darauf hinweist dass sie mist entschieden
haben aber glücklicherweise ist es bei uns so groß und breit dass die die man da anpisst
aus management nicht die sind die im endeffekt über die ganze höchstentscheiden also das
würde sich dann auch gefallen lassen das ist ja auch das was ich bei uns so ein bisschen
vermisse ist also die selbstkritik im management wenn man sachen entschieden hat die halt nicht
gut gelaufen sind ich erwarte ja noch nicht mal dass sich jemand hinstellt und sagt oh
jungs wir haben es voll verkackt jetzt macht ja keiner gerne aber dass man zumindest sagt
ok wir sind jetzt schlauer machen machen uns da in zukunft mal mehr gedanken drüber oder
wir würden das jetzt anders entscheiden irgendwie sowas aber das passiert bei uns nicht und
wie gesagt ich habe mich schon öfters mal unbeliebt gemacht weil ich das auf irgendwelchen
retrospectiven oder anderen runden angesprochen habe zum beispiel letztens hat auch wieder
irgendeiner was erzählt von synergie effekten nutzen ja also nach dem motto hier können
wir das zusammen machen dann nutzen wir synergie effekte hier können wir da nutzen wir synergie
effekte habe ich auch gesagt was was genau verspricht man sich denn für synergie effekte
ja kam dann auch nicht so viel zum beispiel hat jemand ernsthaft behauptet mal von der
weile kein kein spaß leute kein spaß könnt ihr euch nicht ausmalen es hat wirklich mal
von einer weile behauptet ja es wäre jedoch eine gute idee wenn man windows administration
und linux administration irgendwie zusammen fasst weil da könnte man synergie effekte
nutzen habe ich mir dann nur gedacht habe ich mir gedacht dass es das kommt raus wenn
derjenige der das theoretisch auf bvl niveau sieht keinen blassen schimmer hat von dem
was ist was er eigentlich erzählt ja und vorher auch niemand gefragt hat es wissen müsste
es ist ein synergie effekt ja ich habe gehört wenn das besonders viele gleichzeitig anklicken
ist der synergie effekt oder iku gewinn noch besonders hoch und ich habe noch in twitch
intern eine challenge dass ich mehrfach einen halb train über stufe 1 erreichen muss wisst
ihr was es bringt wenn man diese challenge komplettet es bringt gar nichts außer dass
man ein häkchen dran hat dass man diese challenge komplettet hat das ist glaube ich somit unser
nächste feature wo ich nicht verstehe was warum es das gibt aber ok na gut doch ich
verstehe es zumindest ein bisschen warum es das gibt dass das das motiviert leute irgendwie
dann mehr zu streamen und keine ahnung mir ist das wurscht so ich fange an ich fange
also real lpk sagt lpk das sagt mir irgendwas gab es nicht früher mal jemand der call of
duty videos gemacht hat der auch lpk hieß das bist du wahrscheinlich nicht aber irgendwie
kommt mir das bekannt vor ok ich fange im september mit 25 noch eine ausbildung an als
fiesi hat noch eine zweite ausbildung an als fiesi was hast du denn bis jetzt gemacht
was in der richtung was ganz was anderes so ich habe mir dazu ein buch mit ach ich weiß
nicht ok wer meint muss ich jetzt mal angucken fach ach das ist das kannst du knicken das
brauchst du nicht kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das da sinnvoll ist ok ich meine es
hat ziemlich gute amazon bewertung ich meine vielleicht ist es vielleicht ist es gar nicht
schlecht immerhin das buch hat gute bewertung ja und aber diese gerade durch meine frage
wer jetzt ob das denkst ob das sinnvoll ist beziehungsweise was hältst du von so einer
bühne wenig weil ich mein was soll denn eigentlich ein fachinformatiker buch machen ich muss
mir ich gucke mal ich gucke mir mal kurz das inhalt verzeichnis an da gucken wir mal in
als verzeichnis haben wir da irgendwie sowas gibt es in als verzeichnis ich welche sachen
in c gut ist immerhin zähne ich z plus plus in als verzeichnis also ok was gibt es überblick
die ausbildung grundbegriffe der informationstechnik mathematisch und technisch grundlagen hardware
betriebs ok matte ist nun wirklich in der fachinformatik ausbildung im vergleich zum
studium nur wirklich ja gar nicht das was du nachschlagen willst steht da wahrscheinlich
eh nicht drin so hat man betriebs den winnows linux os x grundlagen programming ja ich
meine so ganz grob jquery aktuell keil aktuelle themen jquery also da fällt mir nichts mehr
zu einer keine ahnung ich meine als überblick so wenn man aber ich meine du machst es ja
nicht weil es sich also ich muss das ja interessieren sonst wird sie ja die ausbildung nicht machen
also ganz grob als überblick vielleicht aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht dass es dir
großartig was bringt und zwar aus folgendem grund es ist so betriebsabhängig was du
machst wahrscheinlich wird dir 90 prozent von diesen themen gar nicht gar nichts bringen
ja stellen wir mal stell dir mal vor du landest jetzt in einem bereich wo du hauptsächlich
was weiß ich netzwerk equipment betreust so also da bringt dir das meiste hier von gar
nichts und das was du lernen musst das lernst du in der prüfungsvorbereitung oder ein bisschen
auch in der berufsschule also es ist halt so das ist zwar ein riesen gebiet was man machen
kann aber unterm strich macht man am ende halt nur einen kleinen teil davon nee also
ich glaube nicht dass es großartig was bringt ehrlich gesagt wenn ich mir das jetzt so recht
überlege glaube ich nicht dass es viel bringt vor allem auch 1500 seien da bist ja bist
ja ordentlich beschäftigt also ich denke es ist besser wenn du weißt wo du anfängst
und die sagen dir was sie ungefähr machen und du holst dir dann was themenspezifisches
ja wenn die jetzt sagen hey wir programmieren ganz viele ruby was kaum einer macht aber
nur als beispiel da kann sie ein ruby buch holen oder wenn die sagen ja wir machen ganz
viele cisco switcher da kannst du dir da irgendwie schon ein bisschen was durchlesen davor aber
eins muss man ja auch mal sagen also der betrieb ist dafür verantwortlich dich auszubilden
dementsprechend die müssen jetzt weil ich alles vorkauen aber die müssen dir zumindest
guides ja führer der führer ist in deutschland so schlecht leider etwas negativ vorbesetzt
guide für dich sein was denn jetzt was du jetzt machen sollst die können dich ja nicht
von rechner pflanzen und sagen ok in drei jahren zur abschlussprüfung sehen wir uns
wieder das machen bestimmt genug betriebe aber gute ausbildung ist was anderes bei mir
war das in der ausbildung tatsächlich gut wie gesagt ihr wisst die ausbildung nicht
beim provider gemacht habe ich fand den arbeitgeber im nachhinein ziemlich kacke ja aber ich bin
ja dann da auch weg aber eins war tatsächlich in der ausbildung relativ gut dadurch dass
es keine ausbildung gab im eigentlichen sinne ist nicht so als hätte ich immer mit dir
hingesetzt hat gesagt hier lass uns mal was angucken mach mal die und die aufgabe ich
guck's mehr war ja nix ja bei uns war das im endeffekt so die haben sich haben sie
von rechner gesetzt und hätten sich drei jahre nicht gerührt bis zur abschlussprüfung
und dann hätten sie dich nicht übernommen oder aber du hattest die chance wenn du dich
einbringen wolltest und wenn dich das interessiert hat interessiert du konntest einfach mitmachen
und dann haben wir die leute auch mal ein bisschen was gezeigt aber nicht so nach dem motto
ja wir gucken uns heute das und das an sondern eher du guckst einem zu wieder ein bisschen
beschriptet fragst ein paar sachen und bastelst dann selber was was das nächste mal irgendwo
verwendet wird und dann geht es nicht und dann machst du es ganz und das war tatsächlich
in der ausbildung ganz gut weil man schlicht und ergreifend was machen muss da musste nicht
aber du hattest du hattest sonst keine chance und man hatte aber viele möglichkeiten wir
hatten unterschiedlich viele rechenzentren das hätte ich alles nicht gesehen hätte ich
nicht die ausbildung beim provider gemacht
tja also wie gesagt ich glaube ich glaube nicht das ist keine off topic frage dafür
mache ich den stream im endeffekt nicht mal kurz die musik ein bisschen leiser mal was
anderes etwas anderes anmachen happy kirby musik wunderbar dafür mache ich die mache
ich die streams letztendlich wenn ich mich einfach nur von rechner setze und stream machen
ich habe ja heute nichts großartig vorbereitet ich habe einfach nur stream angemacht das
heißt wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt haut es in den chat ich habe nichts zu zu reden
wenn ihr nichts schreibt heute wir können uns höchst noch ein paar videos angucken
und dann gehe ich penne in anderthalb stunden weil ich müde wie sauber müde als fuck bin
ja das synergie effekt zwischen windows und linux verstehe ich nicht meinung zu c++ jetzt
hör auf jetzt hört mir auf jetzt kommt als nächstes die meinung zu kobold und zu fortran
und zu ab ab und was sich alles gibt ach ok und ist das jetzt weil du schwierigkeiten
hast also wenn nur wenn du sagen willst ja ist das jetzt weil du schwierigkeiten hast
einen job zu finden als als lagerkraft oder ist das was weil du sagst ich will jetzt was
anderes machen für die basics ok finde ich wie gesagt ich glaube nicht dass es was bringt
gibt es heute java stream weder noch es gibt kein programmier ist immer noch kein java
stream ja das stimmt wohl bist du immer noch ruby ja ruby ist finde ich eines der schönsten
programmiersprachen die es gibt aber leider ich habe übrigens gelesen dass ruby on rails
irgendwann dem letzt auch ja hier im märz ist eine neue version rausgekommen das letzte
mal dass ich mit rails was gemacht habe war glaube ich version 4 oder so aber rails war
halt früher echter shit und ruby ist immer noch eine super programmiersprache wie gesagt
leider nicht mehr so angesagt also killua spike sagt ich hatte letztens mit einem arbeitskollegen
eine meinung verschieben oder muss ich was erzählen leute ich hatte gestern auch ich
habe mich gestern mit einem offen meeting auf einer auf einer auf einer change runde
in den haren gehabt das muss ich gleich erzählen das ist das ist lustig was man was mit manchen
leuten dann wieder ab geht natürlich bin ich fest davon überzeugt dass ich recht habe
dementsprechend werde ich euch das jetzt auch so erzählen als ist der andere blöd und ich
schlau natürlich gehe ich davon aus dass ich recht habe ja ist ja klar ok ich lese
das mal kurz die frage also ich hatte letztens mit mit einem arbeitskollegen eine meinungsverschiedenheit
darüber wie detailliert eine webapp ihre internen fehler als error zurückgeben soll da kann
man sicherlich auch viel darüber diskutieren spätestens beim stack trace würde ich nicht
raushauen ich meine es gibt es gibt ja manche backends die browser erweiterungen haben um
dann fehlermeldung im development modus schön anzeigen zu können ja das ist gut aber irgendwas
programmieren für irgendwelche stacktracks ich weiß ja nicht also im live betrieb wenn
du da irgendwie was weiß ich config release oder config irgendwas einschaltet sollte das
ding definitiv kein stacktrace raushauen muss es ja auch gar nicht weil dein backend kann
das ja locken dafür lockt man ja im backend dass man den kram nicht als response in ich
mein was geht was geht es den typ an der die api abfragen ob er euch jetzt irgendwie null
pointer exception oder sowas im backend aufgetreten ist im zweifelsfall und du weißt wie ausführlich
manchmal die dinger sind zeigt dass die ja sogar noch zeilen an code an drum herum und
wenn du wenn du pech hast steht dann im zweifelsfall noch irgendwas sensitives damit drinne oder
so weil irgendjemand wie irgendjemand hat die variablen so benannt sprechen nach irgendwas
internem was auch immer ja also stundenlang in die log so etwas ist bescheuert also das
ist wirklich bescheuert stacktrace hat finde ich in einer hardtp response in gonics zu
suchen es wäre gern man muss immer muss eh sagen dass htp error codes ganz schön hart missbraucht werden in vielen webanwendungen
hatte tp error codes sind ansinnten sind da um anzuzeigen fehler oder oder status im webserver
sobald das ding zu deinem api endpunkt kommt müsste man eigentlich rein theoretisch sagen
das ist immer ein 200 egal ob fehler macht man aus praktischen gründen nicht verstehe
ich auch aber also es gibt ja auch noch was dazwischen also das ist jetzt die totale übertreibung
ja und dann im response quasi noch irgendwie wahrscheinlich irgendwie noch ein riesen jason
body mit zu schicken mit einem megabyte stacktrace oder so nee das würde ich nicht machen dafür
kann man den kram locken im backend und gut ist und ganz ehrlich viele locks sind schon
nicht hilfreich da will ich nicht wissen wie hilfreich ist oder wie wenig hilfreich meistens
ein stacktrace in der hardtp response ist das musste dann auch erst mal irgendwie richtig
zuordnen nee also das finde ich bescheuert immer 418 zurückgeben ist 418 der t-pot aber
hatte tp 418 oder es ist die brieftaube es gibt auch so paar mime ja ein betrieb gibt
auch so paar hatte im mime hatte tp status codes ich bin eine t-kerne ne also das finde
ich blödsinnig hier dass das stacktrace zurückzugeben also ich meine was man machen kann ist zum
beispiel wenn das frontend das verarbeiten kann wenn man ein formular hat und gibt dann
ein error jason objekt zurück dass man in diesem formular schön anzeigen kann beim
feld vorname darf kein leerzeichen sein oder oder beim feld email das sieht nicht aus
wie eine email oder sowas das ist ja alles in ordnung aber ein stacktrace dann ist das
irgendwann auch mal gut
ich bin schon seit jahren im artilbereich interessiert achso ach hier das ist fahrinformatik
ausbildung und weiß dass ich viel mit linux zu tun haben werde das ist schon mal gut wenn
du viel mit linux zu tun hast würde ich dir eine sache empfehlen installiere mal und nein
das ist jetzt kein blödes arch by the way installiere mal ein paar linux distributionen
in der vm und ich würde dir empfehlen folgende äh folgende drei stück zu nehmen erstens
arch linux für zum lernen ähm als hauptsächlich halt letztendlich als desktop system auch
wenn du es vielleicht auf der arbeit nicht brauchst aber man lernt einiges dabei und
ein chat ich würde nicht empfehlen gento selbst zu kompilieren installiere den arch linux
und richte das mal ein installiere dir ein debian und installiere dir mal ein red hat
oder ein was ist es jetzt in rocky linux also installiere was red hat basiertes installiere
mal was was debian basiertes kann auch ein ubuntu oder was sein und installiere mal ein
arch linux in der vm und bastel mal ein bisschen mit rum und versuch mal beispielsweise deine
arch linux vm ähm von der minimal installation so einzurichten dass du ein desktop bekommst
mit dem desktop environment und so da lernt man schon einiges dabei vor allem linux kommando
zeilen bedienung weil eine sache die ich festgestellt habe die gerade linux neulinge gerne machen
ist die versuchen dann irgendwie zwangsweise dinger im gui zu machen so nach dem motto
weil die leute wissen von windows terminal ist böse aber unter windows liegt das daran
weil das terminal was standardmäßig dabei ist also das terminal und die shell einfach
nur kompletter bullshit ist also hier diese cmd und diese was ist das batch programmier
script sprache ist wirklich aus der hölle komplett leute die das kennen da wundert
mich nicht dass die angst vor linux kommando zeilen haben aber das ist der unterschied
ist halt linux kommando zeilen ist gut batch cmd ist halt abgrund tiefer rotz und selbst
powershell finde ich nicht gut powershell finde ich gut als script im umgebung aber powershell
finde ich nicht gut als interaktive shell ok zumindest bin ich so weit interessiert
dass ich mir gerne privat die freizeit nehmen um alles mögliche zu lernen da ich system
integration extrem interessant finde es hat nur ein paar jahre gedauert eine stelle als
physik zu bekommen echt ich dachte die sind aktuell alle wie verrückt auf der suche deswegen
will ich diese chance ja das finde ich finde ich nice da sieht man aber auch mal wieder
man ist da nie zu spät ich hatte beispielsweise auch in der berufsschule einer war damals
schon 35 und hatte super abschlussprüfung gemacht also der ist jetzt zwar jünger als
ich jetzt aber das ist ja auch schon ein bisschen her wo ich in der berufsschule gewesen bin
es gibt sich mehr das heizungsdashbot ich habe es gerade noch laufen aber das heizungsdashbot
sammelt keine daten mehr ein ist es normal dass man von 30 bewerbungen auf fünf antworten
bekommt für was bewirbst du dich als ausbildung oder als ja job quasi später also wenn du
im it sektor bist und irgendwie nur ein bisschen bisschen was gefragtes kannst dann wunderts
mich dass nur so so so wenige antworten weil die sind eigentlich aktuell alle hände regend
auf der suche und kommen dir da auch ziemlich weit entgegen ach so fahrinformatiker systemintegration
ja hängt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen auch vom standort ab beziehungsweise von der von
der region vielleicht ist die bewerbung aber auch kacke das kann ja auch sein das weiß
ich jetzt natürlich nicht möglich man weiß es nicht ja fünf in mathe auch ja ok ok das
interessiert vielleicht welche die bvl studiert haben unter meinung sind an fahrinformatiker
braucht unbedingt hier eine einzeln mathe das aber schwachsinn aber gut das bringt ja
dir nichts wenn ich dir das jetzt sage das müsste ja die muss in die personal abteilung
so sehen aber ich finde es ist nicht wirklich aussagekräftig du ist du studierst ja nicht
informatik sondern du machst eine fahrinformatik ausbildung die fahrinformatik ausbildung was
du da an mathe machst ist wirklich hauptschule doch nicht mal das ist irgendwas was man mal
so in sechsten siebten klasse ein bisschen nebenbei gemacht hat machst du du machst
eigentlich nix großartig was hältst du denn von der benennung von usb standards dazu lasse
ich mich heute auch nicht aus ihr wisst dass ich die ziemlich bescheuert finde was wäre
dir lieber only homeoffice oder zwei bis drei tage die woche zur arbeit warum nicht also
warum gibt es nur diese zwei sachen zur auswahl warum gibt es nicht was dazwischen warum gibt
es nicht zum beispiel hier zur auswahl dass ich sagen dass man sagen könnte ok einmal
die woche ach so doch ich weiß warum das sein könnte weil man dir wahrscheinlich kein
arbeitsplatz dann vorhalten muss oder deine berufsberaterin verzweifelt du darfst nicht
den fehler machen davon auszugehen dass deine berufsberaterin dich berät also das was ich
bisher vom arbeitsamt an berufsberater und berufsberaterinnen gesehen habe war ganz furchtbar
schlecht die erzählen ja beispielsweise auch du sollst was mit holz machen obwohl das überhaupt
nichts für dich ist aber sie halt offene ausbildungsstelle für was mit holz haben nix
gegen leute die was mit holz machen das will ich nicht sagen ja
naja du musst dich nicht arbeitslos melden du musst das du musst also kann ich da zwingt
dich keiner zu es ist empfehlenswert später für rentenversicherung und sowas aber letztendlich
wieviel dir dann unterm strich durch die lappen geht muss man mal ausrechnen ob das der stress
wert ist keine ahnung also ich würde mich nie wieder arbeitslos melden ich hab das auch
gemacht wo ich jünger war so ungefähr in deinem alter würde ich mal sagen habe ich
das auch gemacht habe ich ja schon mal ein video darüber aufgenommen arbeitsamt ist
der größte kackverein überhaupt also ja warum denn nur die zwei sachen zur auswahl also
wenn ich mir okay wenn ich mich zwischen diesen zwei sachen real pk dann für den sap wenn
ich mich wirklich zwischen diesen zwei sachen entscheiden müsste dann only home office weil
ich arbeite nur vier tage die woche und für mich kommt es nicht in frage drei also die
hälfte davon mit der bahn zu fahren das würde ich auf gar keinen fall machen wenn zur arbeit
bedeutet das ist bei mir zu fuß erreichbar um die ecke das könne man sich vielleicht
überlegen aber ich fahre nicht mehr die hälfte oder oder 80 prozent der woche meiner arbeitswoche
nach frankfurt mit der bahn ja 9 euro ticket ist egal das geht mir nicht um den preis ich
habe überhaupt kein problem mein monat ticket zu bezahlen zu normalen preis ich finde zwar
zu teuer was normale tickets kosten aber das nicht mein problem ein problem ist dass die
bahn überhaupt nicht zuverlässig ist zuverlässig und unwill und und und willens da irgendwas
dran zu ändern dazu kommt auch noch das alles nicht direkt was mit dem was mich täglich
nervt zu tun aber generell in welchem zuschern das auch alles ist ja ich meine da könnte
ich drüber hinweg sehen wenn die bahn denn pünktlich kommen würde oder immer halbwegs
pünktlich kommen würde und mich dann davon a nach b bringt das ist ja wisst ihr das ist
ja meiner meinung das kernziel von der bahn was sie was sie erfüllen muss aber nicht
erfüllt aber da ist drum herum auch so viel in absolut miesem zustand ich meine jetzt
noch nicht mal dass es keine sauberen close gibt teilweise im zug das geht sogar halbwegs
manchmal es ist eher so sachen wie dass es mittlerweile so viele bahnhöfe gibt wo es
noch nicht mal ein klo gibt selbst in hanau gab es mal eine zeit lang keinen klo und hanau
ist einer der größten bahnhöfe in deutschland wie kann es sein dass es da kein klo gibt
da gab es dann irgend so ein kleines scheiß haus vorm haupteingang wurde dann zwei euro
reinschmeißen muss und dann hast du zwei euro reingeschmissen ist jetzt kein kein kein
spaß leute du bist du bist auf den du bist zum haupteingang gegangen vom hanauer bahnhof
davor stand dann so ein selbstreinigendes scheiß haus oder hast du zwei euro reingeschmissen
und du musstest mal mega aufs klo und dann war so ein kleines schild stand dann da unten
drunter booting das klo hat gebootet nachdem ich irgendwie noch mal zwei minuten nachdem
ich da ein paar euro reingeschmissen habe booting stand auf dem klo und ich stehe da
vor da hat man leute ich kacke gleich in die hose lasst mich rein sondern hat das fertig
gebootet war noch komplett nass drum herum weil es dann frisch gereinigt wurde und dann
war noch nicht mal klo papier am ende drin also ganz im ernst schlimm also dass der kram
auch in so einem miesen zustand ist ja da haben wir auch genug leute die der meinung
sind sie müssen sich nicht bei aktuellen sachen auf dem laufenden halten da habe ich
es ganz gut und wisst ihr warum weil ich videos mache und weil ich live streams mache wo wir
uns auch öfters mit neuer technik beschäftigen und weil mich neue sachen interessieren ich
war bisher eigentlich immer der meinung dass das ein eine grundvoraussetzung ist dafür
dass man überhaupt fachinformatiker werden kann oder ich war aber dass man in die dass
man im alti bereich arbeiten kann ich dachte eigentlich früher und eigentlich immer ich
denke es immer noch dass interesse oder so neugierige neugierig sein auf neue entwicklungen und
die ausprobieren wollen das heißt nicht unbedingt gleich damit ein produktivsystem hinstellen
aber ausprobieren wollen und auch irgendwie spaß daran haben die dann möglichst perfekt
einzurichten und so die details rauszubekommen und und irgendwie dann eine kurze knackige
config zu basteln die das dann elegant löst was man machen will so das würde ich jetzt
eigentlich von ausgehen das ist was was allen leuten in der it spaß macht aber ich habe
jetzt auch öfters gelernt das ist leider nicht so wir haben auch leute auf der arbeit da
denke ich mir was ist da los wir haben beispielsweise jemand bei uns der kümmert sich um email
postfächer und sowas es ist nicht so deck der kann der kann ich sagen was ein map ist
und so dass das das funktioniert schon aber wenn der drei zeilen bash scripten soll um
irgendwie mal die plattenauslastung von unserem storage back end da auszulesen und ordentlich
darzustellen das ist schon zu viel verlangt das guten da denke ich mir auch gut ich mein
bash ist jetzt sicherlich nicht die schönste sprache aber so schwer ist es jetzt auch nicht
und ich hätte da bock drauf ich habe auch schon öfters bei uns auf der arbeit gesagt
wenn es darum ging irgendwas zu skripten oder irgendwas zu programmieren ich habe schon
ich habe schon öfter so ich mache das kein ding ich habe da bock drauf aber gibt leute
die finden das wolltest du nicht ein story erzählst mache ich sobald ich gerade den chat
weil ansonsten kann ich den zusammen machen gar nicht mehr die haben gesagt bash ist nicht
sondern nicht intuitiv aber ich meine so schwer ist es jetzt auch nicht wusste dir eigentlich
achtung bash hack 2022 wusste die einfach ist denn jetzt meine vm auch nicht meine vm
ist gar nicht auswärts gebadet passt mal auf bashack 2022 zeige ich jetzt mal was wahrscheinlich
sagt der chat jetzt wieder max recycle story das kennen wir doch alle schon ich benutze
das schon seit 150 jahren aber vielleicht lernt ja der ein oder andere doch noch was
weil ich finde das ist was das ist praktisch bash also bashack 2022 mit max also starten
wir erstmal den bash max at poggers so guckt mal wahrgenommen ihr macht jetzt sowas hier
okay ich brauche jetzt ein blödes beispiel ja wahrgenommen ihr macht jetzt sowas hier
echo geheimes password pipe nach irgendwas ja mysql backup oder so wahrgenommen ihr macht
sowas so dann ist das problem dass wenn ihr in eure history guckt dann steht dann drinnen
echo geheimes password wisst ihr was ihr machen könnt dass das nicht in der history steht
ihr macht einfach ein leerzeichen davor und jetzt führt ihr das noch mal aus und guckt
mir history und siehe was ist denn das
das geht das geht eigentlich ist das irgendeine bash rc geschichte wie sieht es in zsh aus
history guckt ne hier funktioniert das auch nicht sag mal habe ich das habe ich das irgendwie
überschrieben dass das das nicht geht also normalerweise ist das default wenn ihr ein
leerzeichen macht kommt es nicht in die history warum das bei mir in meiner vm nicht so ist
ich habe keine ahnung könnte sie eine t max geschichte sein ok bash echo keck weh so
echo 123 keck weh history nee das ist arsch ja das ist bei dir geht's also ich habe keine
ahnung warum das nicht funktioniert es ist eigentlich default setting wow was ist denn
hier alles drinne alter was denn das das habe ich nicht eingestellt was ich habe ich habe
bash noch nie benutzt hier warum ist das in meiner bash rc drinne ok ok ok ich weiß nicht
warum aber ich muss mal kurz meine bash rc irgendwo hin bester name so nochmal bash starten
history ok so leerzeichen history was zum teufel ist das gut ich habe keine ahnung aber
es ist normalerweise default dass es nicht in der history steht wenn man leerzeichen
davor macht also auf jeder standardinstallation ob und du debian redhead sonst was geht das
bei mir anscheinend nicht ist mir neu aber ok wüsste ich jetzt nicht woran das liegt
wenn ich ehrlich bin ich weiß es nicht aber besser hack überhaupt das könnt ihr euch
merken das ist tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll warum es bei mir nicht geht ich habe keine
ahnung ja ich weiß dass es geht ich habe keine ahnung warum es bei mir nicht geht
vielleicht muss man das auch vielleicht muss man das einschalten und das ist normalerweise
standardmäßig drinne bei den anderen keine ahnung also mir war es so als ist das ist
das default arch by the way so bleeding edge dass so sachen nicht mehr funktionieren ja
also wie gesagt das das verstehe ich teilweise auch nicht wie leute seit 30 jahren sich nichts
neues angeguckt haben teilweise ja verstehe ich verstehe nicht ist eigentlich gar nicht
möglich aber irgendwie dann doch was sagst du zur battle field 2042 season 1 ich habe
es mir runtergeladen ich werde wahrscheinlich morgen noch mal anspielen und dann sage ich
vielleicht über morgen was zu morgen lade ich erst mal was zu diablo immortal hoch einfach
damit ich mich da auch mal zu ausgelassen habe ja das haben wir uns schon angesehen
github hat heute announced dass sie den atom ach ja wirklich dann ist ja wishlist die code
der einzig überlebende aus diesen aus diesen reihen es gab damals zu dieser zeit vielleicht
ändert sich noch da ein oder andere es gab zuerst atom und dann in relativ kurzer folge
brackets und visual studio code ich weiß nicht ob es brackets noch gibt das war eigentlich
von adobe das war eigentlich ein ganz cooler ansatz ok gibt es nicht mehr ist auch ist
auch eingestellt ja und brackets war auch ganz cool da konnte man live html editieren
du hast eine plause auf gehabt und auf der anderen seite editor das war war cool aber
anscheinend von diesen standard javascript editoren die damals mal aufgekommen sind
das studio code so wie es scheint nur der einzig überlebende mittlerweile zu recht
auch irgendwo weil visual studio code halt mittlerweile wirklich gut ist man kann von
microsoft halten was man will aber visual studio code ist wirklich nicht schlecht aber
nichtsdestotrotz atom legacy läuft weiter chat wer weiß noch wie sich electron in der
ersten version nannte oder in den ersten ausgaben nannte wie hieß das was heute electron ist
die ersten paar versionen lang vielleicht weiß das noch jemand brat es jetzt einfach mal
in die runde anscheinend weiß es keiner das hieß atom shell aus atom shell ist electron
geworden später 2015 ist es aber schon her warum hieß das atom shell weil dieses ding
damals für den github code editor erfunden wurde also man könnte quasi sagen visual
studio code baut auf einer atom technologie auf ja richtig pepega oder warum nicht das
ist doch gar nicht also ich finde es zwar merkwürdig dass irgendwie nach zwei jahren
schon der krasse senior checker ist aber warum nicht wenn die das bezahlen ist doch alles
in ordnung und ansonsten ist das was er verdient ungefähr das was ich auch kriege und wenn
ich in frankfurt rumgucke ist da noch deutlich mehr drin wenn ich nicht so ein fauler sack
wäre und mich auch mal ein bisschen umgucken würde aber vielleicht bleibt mir amnächst
nichts anderes übrig weil ich dann sage ich mache mich vom acker je nachdem was mit homeoffice
läuft ja aber das ist ein komisches argument da kann man stundenlang die logs durchgucken
man kann auch stundenlang die stacktrace antworten dann durchgucken die man nicht richtig zuordnen
kann und mal ganz davon abgesehen wenn man versucht irgendwie halbwegs gescheit zu loggen
was ja mittlerweile bei den meisten web frameworks also backend geschichten eingebaut ist kann
man relativ gut seine logs durchsuchen also die meisten logging sachen wenn man sie denn
benutzt und nicht so wie ich einfach stupide console log macht oder console write line
verwendet sondern wenn man den im framework eingebauten logger verwendet dann loggt er
meistens auch raus welches modul ist das inklusive der exception inklusive der error stufe inklusive
der zeit man kann die auch relativ gut konfigurieren also sprich wenn man unix timestamps haben
will man utc haben will man nach keine ahnung immer zu einem syslog schicken also ich glaube
man ist schneller durch die logs auf backend als für irgendwelche stacktraces im htp aber
gut ich mein kann man nichts machen wenn er der meinung ist dann kann man sich wahrscheinlich
schlecht ausreden geil ja das passiert manchmal wenn die ihre seiten im development modus
starten das sind irgendwelche stacktraces rausgeholt ich hatte es mal vor jahren ist
wirklich schon ewig her da bin ich auf der pp seite gegangen und wisst ihr was gekommen
ist es ist eine exception gekommen und in der ex oder wie nennt man das bei pp es ist
eine exception so ein pp stacktrace ist gekommen und im pp stacktrace stand irgendein credential
drinne irgendein secret ich weiß nicht genau für was es ist aber war halt bisschen unglücklich
im source code platziert und da hat man halt das secret im klartext in der exception oder
im stacktrace gesehen halt auch ziemlich bescheuert keine ahnung ich mein pp erfahrung ist relativ
lange her
wird schon dreimal gescheit und wir haben es doch letztens erst im stream gemacht das
war doch gar nicht so schwer du installierst arch mit dem installer script installierst
ein x installierst den i3 gaps oder normales i3 und machst start x i3 und dann gehts eigentlich
ist das jetzt arch by the way da gibt es da gibt es die meinungen gehen auseinander ob
das arch by the way ist also ich würde sagen ja das ist arch by the way aber nachdem das
noch die vm auf manjaro basis ist könnte man auch argumentieren das ist nicht arch
by the way es ist manjaro by the way
in zwei wochen hast du mündliche abschlussprüfung und was wie würdest du es einschätzen blickst
du durch hast du denn schon mal alte abschlussprüfung gemacht weil wenn nicht würde ich dir unbedingt
ans herz legen macht noch mal 45 abschlussprüfung man macht eigentlich jeder aber ich sag es
halt einfach mal nur weil falls es wirklich jemand gibt der das nicht macht mach noch
mal 45 abschlussprüfung der vergangenen jahre und guck dir an was dabei rausgegangen
ist ach mündliche abschlussprüfung habe ich nicht gekriegt sehen ok vergiss es habe
ich nicht gesehen ja dann hast du die schriftliche schon geschafft alles klar dann ist ja gut
ja mündliche abschlussprüfung bei mir habe ich ja schon mal ein video drüber gemacht
die lief ja richtig beschissen das hier aber nicht wegen der ea k sondern wisst ihr was
mir mal auffällt das bettel viel drei tatsächlich selbst in low settings immer noch ganz brauchbar
aussieht man das ist jetzt keine augenweide ja und gerade in low settings bestimmt jetzt
auch nicht best game optisch aber es sieht doch echt noch ganz brauchbar aus naja zumindest
was ich in dem video sage ist halt kurz zusammengefasst ich wurde von ihr k angerufen und die haben
mir gesagt ich bin durchgefallen und das obwohl ich noch nicht bei der prüfung war und irgendwie
ist ihr server abgekackt als ich meine meinen antrag hochgeladen habe und dann haben sie
gesagt ja das muss ja wohl an ihnen liegen sondern das liegt nicht an mir ich habe sogar
die bestätigung email von euch
schon gesehen traue ich mich jetzt das aufzumachen die geheimpolizei wie facebook seine mitarbeite
über ich habe mal kurz reingeguckt ja das problem ist immer wenn ich mir so was angucke
ich krieg dann immer so halb paranoia dass das bei mir auch so ist und ich ziehe teilweise
im teams schon ganz schön über andere leute über die firma und eigentlich so ziemlich
alles mögliche her ich glaube aber nicht dass es bei meinem unternehmen wo ich arbeite
auch so ist weil naja irgendein vorteil dass man in deutschland seinen sitz hat muss es
ja haben hoffe ich sehr interessant dass wir okay komm uns vielleicht nachher an du hast
65 65 bewerbung gebraucht das ist aber ganz schön viel die suchen alle zumindest sagen
sie es immer dass sie alle hände ringt azubis suchen und gerade als abgebrochener informatik
studenten mögen die dich normalerweise also entweder sind die bewerbung ganz furchtbar
pepega oder irgendwas ist komisch das ist das das haben wir schon aufgemacht das ist
übrigens der grund warum so viele wirtschaftsinformatik studieren könnte ich wecken es studieren so
viele wirtschaftsinformatik weil sie schiss formate im informatik studium haben
na dann hast du doch ahnung davon das würde ich übrigens auf jeden fall in die bewerbung
reinschreiben gell also wenn du irgendeine bewerbung schreibst würde ich gerade wenn
es was wenn wenn es in den laden ist wo du absehen kannst dass die bissl was mit linux
machen würde ich das schon mal an klingen lassen dass man da ahnung von hat das wäre
für mich auch ein grund jemand einzuladen ehrlich gesagt also wenn irgendjemand sachen
wie kuemo und gpu pass und ubuntu und mqtt was auch immer droppt den würde ich lieber
einladen als irgendjemand der ein bisschen bessere noten hat aber das problem ist halt
je nachdem wo du dich bewirbst kommt es halt bei der personalabteilung raus und die personalabteilung
hat halt irgendso einen anforderungszettel und wenn dann darauf steht eine 5 im zeugnis
ist ausschlusskriterium dann juckt das die personalabteilung nicht das problem ist halt
dass die bei der personalabteilung halt von der eigentlichen sache dann überhaupt keine
ahnung haben
also ich muss sagen meine aus meiner ausbeute damals war auch nicht sonderlich gut prozentual
gesehen aber ich habe doch glaube ich insgesamt nur nicht viele leute es kann sein dass es
nicht ganz stimmt ich habe fünf bewerbung geschrieben damals und ich habe eine absage
gekriegt und dann wurde ich beim provider genommen also das ging das ging ziemlich ziemlich
zackig nachdem ich mich mal aufgerafft habe bewerbung zu schreiben ich habe mich ja die
ganze zeit davor gedrückt und habe daheim gesessen und habe mmo rpg kreisel grindet
und ich wollte nicht arbeiten weil ich wollte lieber 24 sieben kreisel machen ich mein wer
kennt es nicht ich meine stell euch mal vor ihr seid jung und ihr habt die auswahl arbeiten
gehen oder ausbildung machen oder wobei so jung war ich da gar nicht mehr was erzähle
ich denn für ein mist die erste ausbildung war mein bvl krempel die die ja das war noch
schlimmer aber für die ausbildung zu fahren von martin habe ich insgesamt plus fünf bewerbung
geschrieben irgendwie so in dem dreh und das ging dann relativ schnell aber bei der ersten
ausbildung das war ganz wild ja ich hatte keinen bock ich hatte überhaupt keinen bock
was zu machen jetzt überlegt euch ihr seid jung und ihr habt zur auswahl daheim sitzen
und mmos spielen den ganzen tag oder ausbildung machen gehen was macht ihr ich glaube die
meisten sagen aus bauch aus der klage mmos kreiten natürlich ja es ist jedem klar dass
das in zukunft wahrscheinlich nicht so geil ist wenn man das gemacht hat aber das interessiert
euch in dem moment nicht und das war bei mir auch so und deswegen habe ich damals diese
bescheuerte sache gemacht und habe bürokaufmann gelernt oder angefangen bürokaufmann zu lernen
obwohl ich hasse bvl zeugs jetzt gerade noch mehr und jetzt weiß ich wenigstens auch was
es ist was ich da dran nicht mag aber ich habe das einfach nur gemacht weil es easy
zu bekommen war weil es nicht weit weg war und weil mir meine eltern mega auf den sack
gegangen sind dass ich was machen muss und ich habe mich da überhaupt nicht angestrengt
ja ich war richtig schlecht ich war in der berufsschule ich habe nur fünfer geschrieben
ich war richtig mies es hat mich auch überhaupt nicht interessiert ich habe auch nicht gelernt
oder so ich war einfach nur anwesend wenn ich heim gekommen bin habe ich mmo gespielt
jetzt nicht als advice an die jugend ja und ich war so schlecht in der berufsschule was
bei was die bvl ausbildung angeht aber eine sache eine sache muss sagen es gibt es gibt
durchaus sachen die habe ich mir gemerkt zum beispiel habe ich mir die buchhalternase
gemerkt und das habe ich mir noch gemerkt ich glaube das war es zum größten und ach
so und dass man linear und degressiv abschreiben kann obwohl ich nicht mal genau weiß was es
ist aber die buchhalternase die kenne ich noch das ist die buchhalternase die buchhalternase
die sieht so aus guck das ist das ist die buchhalternase das hier dieses entwertungs
schnörkel da das ist die buchhalternase guck hier das muss man machen damit man seine
bilanz später nicht mehr fälschen fälschen kann und da was hinschreiben ja das habe
ich mir gemerkt aus meiner bvl ausbildung die buchhalternase aber ansonsten keine ahnung
ist nichts mehr hingeblieben ich habe das jetzt ja auch nicht zu ende gemacht ich hätte
es auch ich hätte es im leben auch nicht nicht bestanden so und dann nachdem ich das
gemacht habe und ich so schlecht war haben dann irgendwann auch meine eltern eingesehen
das ist keine gute idee dass ich bvl zeug mache und dann habe ich erst mal zivilins
gemacht zivilins war tatsächlich nicht schlecht gibt es gibt es ja aktuell nicht mehr weil
es keine werpflicht mehr gibt also gibt es auch kein zivilins mehr ich habe zivilins
gemacht in einer behindertenwerkstatt und ich hatte am anfang und ich glaube das geht
jedem so der das gemacht hat ich hatte unglaubliche berührungsängste also was heißt mit berührungs
ich hatte berührungsängste insofern weil ich nicht wusste wie ich mit den leuten umgehen
soll das ist ja quasi wie man kann das vergleichen mit kindergarten nur nur teilweise noch extremer
ja also das war wirklich das war wirklich schocktherapie am anfang weil ich halt überhaupt
nicht wusste wie ich mit den wie ich mit den leuten da umgehen soll aber das ging vorbei
das ging relativ schnell vorbei also relativ schnell das hat ein paar wochen hat er schon
gedauert bis ich mich da eingelebt habe aber im nachhinein betrachtet finde ich dass der
zivilins tatsächlich eines der ja besten dinger kann man nicht sagen weil so geil
war es dann jetzt im endeffekt nicht aber für die persönliche entwicklung ja eines
der besten dinger war die ich gemacht habe also ich meine nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie
weniger menschen hassen würde als vorher aber ich mochte die leute dort und das obwohl
ich menschen nicht mag aber das war irgendwie das war irgendwie was anderes und was ich
auch gelernt habe ist also beim bei meinem zivildienst dass diese leute relativ wenig
lobby haben also sprich es gibt kaum jemand der sich irgendwie für ja bessere bessere
wie soll man sagen bessere lebensbedingungen für behinderte einsetzt gibt es gibt es kaum
und die sind ja auch überall und das ist wahrscheinlich auch in vielen bereichen medizinischen
bereichen so die sind so krass unterbesetzt und reißen sich den arsch da auf also das
habe ich dort zum ersten mal wirklich live erlebt und ich habe auch erlebt dass obwohl
und das hätte ich nie gedacht dass ich mal sowas sagen würde ja also ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass ich als jemand der andere menschen eigentlich überhaupt nicht mag ich muss ich
muss echt sagen die waren auf den ersten blick hat man denken können ja ok die checken alle
nix und die sind blöd und einer wie der andere aber das ist überhaupt nicht so die waren
erstens gar nicht blöd manche waren für das was halt möglich war aber vielen war halt
nicht so viel möglich gut aber wenn du acht minuten kein sauerstoff bei der geburt gekriegt
hast oder sowas da ist halt im hirn auch nicht mal so viel möglich die waren teilweise wirklich
clever und da waren auch viele dabei die deutlich mehr machen hätten können hätte man sie
gefördert als sie dann gemacht haben also da gab es leute dabei hätte man denen wirklich
mal ermöglicht lesen und schreiben zu lernen die hatten da bock drauf die hätten das gekonnt
aber es hat nie sich jemand drum gekümmert und also die waren teilweise deutlich cleverer
als man annehmen mag und das ist eine sache die habe ich die habe ich da gelernt dass
es also erstmal dass es halt auch solche leute gibt und wie individuell dort auch alle leute
sind also ich konnte euch später sagen also ich konnte euch nach weiß ich wie lange das
geht eineinhalb jahre ne ein jahr zivildienst oder so war das weiß gar nicht mehr genau
wie lange die ja ungefähr war das elf monate oder so und ich konnte euch sagen wer welchen
tick hatte also am anfang dachte ich alter die sind doch alle gleich die sind doch alle
bescheuert wie der typ der rapper werden wollte war jemand anderes aber ich bin dann irgendwann
dahinter gekommen die ticken schon alle anders wir hatten beispielsweise eine da die hat
den ganzen ganzen tag immer in ihrem schaukelstuhl geschaukelt und die konnte aber dir sagen
wenn du dir was weiß ich wenn du gesagt hast ich bin am zehnten august 1984 geboren dann
hat die dir gesagt ja das war ein dienstag die konnte sonst nix aber das konnte die oder
wir hatten einen da der hat immer blumen war es runter geschmissen das war rein zum
aufmerksamkeit bekommen ja der hat nicht blumen war es runter geschmissen weil er gerne blumen
war so der wollte aufmerksamkeit haben ja und er ist immer rumgelaufen und überall zu den
leuten hin und hat gefragt hallo darf ich zugucken darf ich zugucken und da habe ich
mir mal überlegt ok was machst du mit dem jetzt und ich habe mich dort mittags um den
um den kiosk gekümmert auch ja also mittags habe ich eineinhalb stunden dort am kiosk
zeug verkauft und ich habe gefressen ohne end aber das was anderes und der kam auch
jeden tag wenn ich dann mittags im kiosk gesessen habe zu mir an kiosk hat gemeint
max max darf ich darf ich hier gucken darf ich gucken darf ich gucken und ich habe halt
immer gesagt nee mach mal platz guck mal hier da stehen so viele leute an aber da kam
jeden tag wieder und irgendwann habe ich mir überlegt weißt du was das nächste mal wenn
der kommt und fragt darf ich gucken dann sagst du einfach ja du darfst gucken und dann kam
der und hat gesagt max darf ich gucken darf ich gucken habe gesagt ja darfst du guck so
lange du willst und dann stand er da keck weight keck weight er hat schlagartig aufgehört
zu nerven weil normalerweise ging es ja immer so darf ich gucken darf ich gucken ich habe
gesagt nee und er hat gesagt warum nicht habe ich gesagt weil so viele leute da stehen ja
aber ich kann mich doch daneben hinstellen darf ich gucken darf ich gucken also das ging
ein viertel stunde lang ich habe gesagt ja du darfst gucken und er stand da der wusste
nicht was er sagen soll und am ende und am ende hat er nach zwei minuten gesagt max
max ich gehe wieder war wieder weg und seitdem durfte er immer gucken das war halt so sein
spiel sein spielchen dabei ja so nachdem auch darf ich gucken oder er hat schon damit gerechnet
dass die leute sagen nein nein geh weg und kann dann diskutieren also die hatten alle
sehr individuelle ticks bin ich auch erst mit der zeit dahinter gekommen also ich muss
sagen so persönlichkeit entwicklungsmäßig war das eines der besten sachen die ich gemacht
habe zivilienz in der behindertenwerkstatt damals das hat mir wirklich eine komplett
andere welt die es so gibt gezeigt nicht dass ich danach irgendwie bock gehabt hätte was
soziales zu machen kollege von mir mit dem ich in der schule war der hatte auch zivilienz
gemacht der hat danach tatsächlich was in dieser richtung angefangen als als arbeit
im leben nicht ja also ich mochte menschen davor nicht ich mochte da menschen danach
auch nicht aber das mal zu erleben für ungefähr einen jahr das war finde ich eine wichtige
sache mein ganzes leben dann bräuchte ich es beim besten wille nicht ok was ist eigentlich
von der her episch was ist von der meinungsverschiedenheit von der berichten wollte es also wir hatten
anfangen diese woche eine ein change oder ich kann es ja sagen das ist ja ein eitel
begriff es gibt ein change advisory board gibt es bei uns das ist im prinzip ein etwas
größeres meeting das schickt jeder bereich ein eitel begriff genau das schickt jeder
bereich vertreter von ihnen hin und dort werden an wartungsarbeiten vorgestellt und wartungsarbeiten
besprochen und man kann nachfragen stellen und man kann gucken passen die zeiten und
weiß die hotline bescheid und solche geschichten kann man da machen ich weiß übrigens gar
nicht was aus dem englischen übersetzt ok was ist das was was ist es denn offiziell
aber gibt es das ist die übersetzung blabla blabla blabla warum ist warum besteht immer
aus so viel text was ist ein change in changes weiß also ok das change advisory board ist
eine krumme formation blabla blabla it umgebung zu werden nach dem eitel change management
prozess ist es als best practice alles klar antragsanfang auf risiken zu prüfen genau
also das gibt es bei uns so change advisory board und es war von dem team in dem ich bin
gab es dort zwei wartungsarbeiten drinne wartungsarbeiten die ich eine woche vorher
schon vorgestellt habe die genehmigt wurden die abgehakt wurden alles in ordnung die standen
diese woche noch mal drin weil sie eine woche verschoben werden mussten so und ich saß
da drin habe gesagt ok also ich saß ich war virtuell per teams dabei und ich habe gesagt
also es ist die gleiche erwartungsarbeit wie von vor einer woche wir haben das ja alle
schon besprochen wurde auch alles schon vorgestellt sogar der ursprüngliche anforderer ist mit
dabei gewesen hat das erklärt eigentlich alles gut wir mussten das bloß eine woche verschieben
weil noch mehr getestet werden musste es ist genau die gleiche warnungsarbeit also ich
sehe da kein problem es ist genau wie letzte woche bloß eine woche später meint der typ
der die verantwortung dafür ja wohl max passt nächstes thema und dann kommt einer unserer
üblichen dampfplauderer so nach dem motto diese änderung klingt aber doch schon relativ
kritisch habt ihr denn daran gedacht gedacht dass dann wenn die nachts durchgeführt wird
auch ein ähm äh auch jemand von der anwendungsentwicklung dabei ist der die logs analysieren kann wir
haben das doch letzte woche besprochen da waren alle damit einverstanden es gibt auch
überhaupt keine probleme und ähm aber ja wenn du der meinung bist da sollte jemand
dabei sein warum nicht aber wir koordinieren das nicht wir sind nur ein teil davon das
ist ein riesenauftrag und wir führen da nur ein paar kommandos aus der eigentliche change
ist viel größer wir beantragen garantiert nicht nacht einsatz für den anwendungsentwickler
der sich nachts logs anguckt so und da meint ihr doch das müsst ihr aber beantragen weil
er hält das schon für sinnvoll sagt jetzt es ist schön und gut wenn es für sinnvoll
ist dann habe ich als irgendwann du bist doch koordinator wenn du das haben willst dann
koordiniert halt dass du jemanden bei schafft für nachts wenn das gemacht wird aber an
irgendeinem admin der da nachts da sitzt an dem kann es ja nicht hängen dass der alle
abhängigkeiten von diesem change drüber und runter irgendwie koordiniert dafür haben
wir change management dafür haben wir koordinatorin du bist koordinator dann koordiniert doch
nein nein so geht das nicht da müsst ihr auf mich zukommen und nicht umgedreht und ich
hatte ich wollte schon was sagen ich wollte schon was sagen ja ich weiß ich habe war schon
kurz kurz vor ausflippen aber ich wollte was sagen und in dem moment kam dann aber unser
change manager hat gemeint jungs jungs bräuchte euch wir reden da nachher noch mal drüber
und wir haben dann auch nachher noch mal drüber geredet und wisst ihr was rausgekommen ist
es ist nicht absolut gar nicht null unsere aufgabe leute für nacht einsätze zu koordinieren
schon gar nicht für irgendein admin der im endeffekt bloß ein paar fehler ausführt
und ein teil des kompletten changes nur ist ja das sind so sachen wo man sich mit business
enterprise bereich rumschlagen muss aber das change management hat uns komplett recht
gegeben hat gesagt ja ist so und es ist halt die leute man die gehen mir teilweise richtig
auf den sack dabei ist das jemand der stiftet immer so verwirrung mit solchen komischen
rückfragen und irgendwelchen einwürfen und dabei ist er gar nicht blöd also von der
technik hat er durchaus ahnung der ist aber finde ich in einer koordinationsrolle komplett
deplatziert der also der bastel lieber selbst als zu koordinieren das ist ja schön ich
wäre froh wenn wir mehr leute hätten die selbst basteln anstatt zu koordinieren aber
der ist halt nur mal in der koordinationsrolle also das ist wirklich das war ganz ganz grausam
und das sind halt so sachen damit muss man sich im business enterprise umfeld auseinandersetzen
was nichts aber auch gar nichts mit den skills zu tun hat die man quasi erwarten würde
die man braucht als fachinformatiker als fachinformatiker oder generell wenn man IT arbeitet wird
man sagen ja ich brauche ahnung von cloud technologien ich brauche ein bisschen ahnung
von programmiersparen ich brauche ein bisschen ahnung von linux ich brauche ein bisschen
ahnung im zweifelsfall von windows ich brauche ein bisschen ahnung von netzwerk und sowas
aber dass man ein bisschen äh ja wie soll ich sagen auch auch resistenz sein muss gegen
sowas das erzählt einem in der ausbildung keiner und ich reg mich eh schon immer relativ
schnell auf bei solchen dingern weil ich hasse es über unsinnige dinger zu diskutieren vor
allem von leuten die dann über dinger diskutieren von denen sie gar nicht wissen was es eigentlich
ist und ich bin da ich bin da kein gutes beispiel für also was so soziale sachen angeht also
es gibt leute die können da deutlich besser kommunizieren und und die haben da wie nennt
man das die besseren soft skills in dieser richtung aber ich ich will die auch gar nicht
haben ich bin damit zufrieden wie es ist und ich bin ja auch kein bvl laber sack sondern
ich bin techniker und das ist mir eigentlich so auch ganz recht aber das war jetzt es gibt
leute die nerven einfach nur ja ja das ist tatsächlich doof weil es bringt
den für die ausbildung überhaupt nix ob die abi haben oder mittelreif das macht legit
keinen absolut keinen unterschied für die ausbildung also wenn ich die auswahl hätte
zwischendurch angenommen ich würde leute einladen für fahrinformatik ausbildung und
irgendjemand schreibt in seine bewerbung rein ja ich bin der max ich hab ich hab abitur
gemacht und meine hobbies sind keine ahnung meine hobbies sind sind modelleisenbahn bauen
und berg steigen sag ich mal ok cool so und dann würde ich deine bewerbung lesen wo drinnen
steht ja ich bin real lpk ich interessiere mich schon seit zehn jahren für linux mein
traum ist es in dem bereich zu arbeiten ich hab mich schon viel beschäftigt mit linux
mit vms mit sonst was dann würde ich ganz klar dich einladen
aber ich bin da nicht in der personalabteilung wisst ihr dass das eine der gründe ist warum
ich glaube dass start ups deutlich effizienter sind als irgendwelche fetten unternehmen es
gibt welche die bekommen die bekommen es hin ich glaube das ist aber einer der gründe
weil dort noch von leuten die von der materie ahnung haben darüber entschieden wird oder
maßgeblich mitbestimmt wird wer eingestellt wird und wenn ich dort die gute leute bekommen
wollen ist das auch so aber es ist in vielen bereichen leider nicht so dann hast du entweder
irgendwelche zwischengeschalteten vermittler die ganz klar vorgaben haben hier wenn der
typ 4 im zeugnis hat dann nehmen wir ihn nicht oder wenn der typ dieses password nicht in
der bewerbung schreibt dann nehmen wir ihn nicht die quasi überhaupt nicht in der lage
sind sich das ein bisschen mit ahnung anzugucken und dann kommt es bei der personalabteilung
raus die noch weniger ahnung hat also da muss man sich auch nicht wundern wenn man keine
gescheiten leute kriegt ich glaube das ist eines der punkte warum start ups so viel effizienter
und innovativer sind usb 3.2 gen 2 x 10 gigabit sein usb 3.2 gen 2 x 2 ist 10 gigabit ist
doch obvious also cringe wer das nicht weiß bei usb standards hyper cringe danke für
den sub so ist es das war bei mir auch so und ich muss doch mal dazu sagen ich hab nichts
dagegen oder will es irgendjemand schlecht reden wenn einer was mit holz macht aber ich
wollte nie was mit holz machen ja schön für alle die gerne was mit holz machen und in
diesem bereich arbeiten können ich bin froh dass es euch gibt es gibt deutlich zu wenig
handwerker und noch viel weniger die ich beauftragen möchte also ich bin froh dass es euch gibt
aber für mich war es nichts mit holz zu machen aber das arbeitsamt damals war der meinung
doch doch max mach was mit holz weil holz ist ja genau das richtige für dich und ich
bin ja erst im nachhinein drauf gekommen meine mutter wusste damals halt auch nicht besser
dass sie dich nicht beraten beim amt was für dich gut ist sondern einzig und allein was
für ihre statistik gut ist das ist der einzige grund warum die dir sowas vorschlagen der
guckt in seine datenbank und sieht wir haben zehn offene schreiner ausbildungsplätze und
dann kriegst du das empfohlen und das schlimme damals war ja dass sie auch noch getan dass
sie so getan haben als wäre das auf grundlage von irgendwelchen analyse ergebnissen ja also
ich habe damals so ein test gemacht beim arbeitsamt wo man ankreuzen konnte was man gerne machen
will also wo dann so seine interessen liegen so was weiß ich was stand in diesem test drinnen
da stand zum beispiel da stand zum beispiel so was drinnen wie arbeiten sie gerne an der
frischen luft oder so was stand da drinnen oder oder arbeiten sie gerne mit technik oder
sowas so und ich habe diesen test damals so ausgefüllt jeden einzelnen punkt quasi im
hinterkopf mit ja ich möchte eben all team mäßig was machen also sprich ich habe dann
angekreuzt ja ich arbeite gerne mit technik ja ich mache das hier gerne oder ich ich mache
auch gerne handwerkliche sachen wenn es eben ums ums da habe ich im hintergrund gedacht
halt quasi computer zusammenschrauben oder so ja so und am ende hat der typ sich noch
drüber lustig gemacht ja ich habe ihm er hat gesagt ok hier ist unsere auswertung für
sie ist eignet sich richtig gut was mit holz habe ich was mit holz ich will nichts mit
holz machen ich habe das alles so angekreuzt im hinblick dass und dass ich was mit hier
arbeiten will wie gesagt das ist schon eine ganze weile her heute ist aber wahrscheinlich
nicht besser und dann hat hat er mir die einzelnen sachen gezeigt und hat gemeint ja aber warum
haben sie denn dann angekreuzt ich würde gerne ich weiß gar nicht was als fragestellte also
sprich warum haben sie denn dann aber warum hast du das war ich ja noch jung aber hast
du dann angekreuzt dass du dann gerne handwerklich arbeitest klar elektronik komponenten zusammenstellen
computer zusammenbauen sowas mache ich gerne und dann hat der typ gesagt das weiß ich heute
noch dieser also was ein mega spaß alter ich weiß es heute noch darauf hat er geantwortet
ja ja alles auf computer ausgerichtet hier das ist so richtig wie der rest wirklich wie
als wäre ich der letzte dumme rex typ den oder raus kriegen muss und er wüsste halt
mega bescheid richtig überheblich ja damals damals habe ich mir sogar so ein bisschen
geschämt habe gesagt wie ich habe den test nicht richtig ausgefüllt also aber nein die
wollten ja nicht dass dieses ergebnis rauskommt was ich was ich eigentlich machen wollte also
den typ gut zum glück bin ich dem nie wieder begegnet ja richtig richtig voll spaß man also
es war komplett für den arsch ja 9 euro tag ist poc was den 15 tagen mündlich abschluss
prüfen zum anwängungsentwickler wünscht mir glück ja ich wünsche dir glück was ist
in dein abschlussprojekt was stellst du was präsentierst du denn was stellst du dann
vor wenn du antwort schreibst schreibt mir entwurplers dabei dass ich dann nachher sehe
ich brauche noch ein bisschen mit dem chat das natürlich schlechter schlechter als lagerarbeit
alle moment du warst nicht das mit dem lagerarbeit
ja habe ich ja gerade ich weiß jetzt hat die chatnachricht schon deutlich älter darf ich
mal kurz kundtun dass ich gerade mikrotik vier virtuelle wlans aufgesetzt habe die auf
die jeweiligen ports gebrütscht sind ultra poc ich weiß wenn ich genau was du gemacht hast
ich weiß auch nicht wie man virtuelle wlans macht weil so eine ss ad und sachen die funken
müssen eh rauskommen sarex was ist toss aber poc poc dass du es hingekriegt hast ja ok hier
hat mich der chat ausgekackt weil ich als ich meinen bash hack zeigen wollte die katze
die liegt irgendwo unten auf dem bett oder so ja die haben als das ding ja fliet
genau haben die rausgebracht mal gucken wie das ankommt noch verhalten wimm ist poc wimm
für kommandozellen editieren ich habe wie gesagt ich war früher richtig übertriebener
wimm fanatiker ja ich habe meinen wimm auf aufgerüstet mit zig plugins teilweise ganz
abgedrehtes zeug und sogar wimm script selber gemacht also wimm script ist wirklich die
ausgeburt des bösen also wenn wenn diablo immortal eine programmiersprache bräuchte
dann wimm script und das ist ganz ganz schrecklich mittlerweile habe ich es aufgegeben und ich
verwende einfach für die sachen wishell studio code oder irgendwie die passende ide aber
wimm verwende ich immer noch täglich für stelles edit hier auf der kommandozelle aber
meine wimmer c ist bei weitem nicht mehr so groß wie früher
echt rust editor gibt es ja ein paar aber davon denen ist keiner wirklich bisher großartig
über die die konzeptionsphase rausgekommen
würde gerne in die branche würde gerne in die IT branche was ist der bessere weg soll
ich eher physik als zweitausbildung machen oder in richtung informatik das kann ich dir
nicht sagen kommt nur an was du machen willst informatik studium ist halt deutlich theoretischer
und du musst wirklich ziemlich intensiv lernen fachinformatik ausbildung kann man auch ohne
viel lernen und hier einen einsatz machen also die einfache variante ist auf jeden fall
eine ausbildung also die weniger anstrengende variante ist auf jeden fall eine ausbildung
also die weniger hirn fordernde sache ist auf jeden fall eine ausbildung und es hat
den vorteil in der ausbildung lernst du was handfestes und hast dann schon ahnung wenn
du fertig bist also das kann ich dir jetzt so schlecht sagen
doch ich glaube das gibt es bei php wirklich
gucken vielleicht schaffe ich das ja mit dem chat heute noch
wirklich da würde ich dir eher fragen woher wisst ihr das dann habt ihr die webexsession
aufgezeichnet da wäre ich an der stelle der firma vorsichtig solche sachen indirekt
zuzugeben duale studium informatik und ausbildung in IT ist ja noch anstrengender wollt ihr
euch alle alle fertig machen oder wie ist schon auf den burn out später im beruf vorbereiten
oder wie machen mit eurer zeit lieber was euch spaß macht ok ich meine es sei denn
es ist genau das was ihr machen wollt und es bringt euch bessere karrieremöglichkeiten
und ihr wollt krassen karriere grind machen und richtig fett kohle verdienen vielleicht
ist es das richtige für euch aber wie gesagt ich kann es ohne kontext da kann ich nichts
zu sagen
kann es sein dass viele junge fachkräfte nachkommen und der markt entsprechend nicht
mehr so aber nö die suchen alle wie verrückt nach leuten wenn du dir jetzt ein sing profil
erstellt man sing ist in deutschland immer noch ein bisschen wenn ihr jetzt ein link
in profil erstellt und da einfach so ein paar 0815 sachen drauf schreibt da hast du nach
ein paar tagen 120 dinger im postfach oder 128 muss ja bein muss ja muss ja zweier potenz
sein die suchen wie verrückt alle deswegen hast du gut deswegen hast du auch gerade gute
chancen relativ viel kohle zu bekommen oder eben halt auch was zu bekommen mit guten arbeitsbedingungen
viel home office und solchen sachen naja gut moment ich rede jetzt nicht unbedingt von
ausbildung ja wenn du wenn du was wenn du wenn du eine ausbildung gemacht hast und suchst
danach was wie gut link in für ausbildung ist bin ich mir nicht sicher weiß ich nicht
ob dann die leute nach so keine ahnung kann ich nicht sagen aber wenn du beispielsweise
ausbildung gemacht hast und schreibst rein so ein paar sachen keine ahnung linux load
balancing hochverfügbarkeitslösungen web server dann kannst du noch reinschreiben dass
du agil bist ahnung von cloud technologien blablabla wenn du so was reinschreibst was
aktuell gefragt ist schreibst rein infrastructure as code schreibst terraform ansible puppet
ein bisschen zeug ein git deffops keine ahnung kann ein bisschen kreativ sein und die rennen
dir aktuell die bude ein shit mein ich ja natürlich shit shit eingecheckt
ist ein außendienst sklave das heißt du durftest zu irgendwelchen technik räumen
oder dinge einbauen am arsch der welt oder wie man darf nicht vergessen also dein arbeitgeber
ist schon also nicht der der der ausbildungs betrieb ist schon verpflichtet die leute auch
auszubilden also man darf die eigentlich nicht drei jahre forsten von rechner setzen und
sagen ja wir sehen uns wieder bei der abschlussprüfung dass es betriebe gibt die das machen ist leider
so aber das ist nicht sinn und zweck der übung ja vielleicht tauschen vielleicht kannst du
einfach nur was beziehungsweise den eindruck gemacht wie gesagt die suchen alle und ich
denke mal dass es in österreich ähnlich ist die suchen alle wirklich viele leute also
die suchen definitiv mehr leute als es leute gibt frei verfügbar das ist soweit dass sie
dich schon abwerben also das ist heutzutage eine tagesordnung dass du abgeworben wirst
von irgendwelchen vermittlern manch einer wird sie headhunter nennen von irgendwelchen
vermittlern die beauftragt werden hier suchen es mal leute und die auch wissen dass viele
leute innerlich gar nicht so sehr am aktuellen arbeitgeber hängen und wenn man denen das
passende angebot macht haben die da schon ein ohr für die versuchen nicht abzuwerben
und das ist ja ganz klar warum naja weil die alle gute leute haben wollen und es halt frei
verfügbar viel viel weniger leute gibt als es bedarf gibt was für uns bester zustand
aller Zeiten ist
ich gehe davon aus dass es so bleiben wird und wisst ihr warum ich davon ausgehe dass
das so bleiben wird weil im vergleich zu vielen anderen bereichen die nachfrage beziehungsweise
die notwendigen stellen im it bereich einfach noch weiter steigt also zum beispiel gehen
wir mal von aus man hat früher irgendwie in der autowerkstatt ja wir machen hier gerne
beispiel mit außen keine ahnung was in der autowerkstatt autos produziert hast du fließbänder
du hast paar maschinen du hast leute die den kram auch programmieren mussten du hast leute
mussten den kram warten und sonst was so und jetzt ist ganz viel davon durch irgendwelche
automatisierung und robotergeschichten ersetzt und es steht quasi nur noch einer am fließband
von früher 10 und es gibt vielleicht auch ja weniger weniger leute was keine ahnung
logistik oder so ich weiß es nicht zumindest für diese zehn leute die weg sind brauchst
du jetzt vielleicht nicht zehn neue leute die den kram warten und programmieren aber
du brauchst vorher vorher hast du vielleicht zwei gebraucht aber jetzt brauchst du fünf
also es fallen zwar mehr jobs weg als gebraucht werden aber die die entstehen die sind höchst
wahrscheinlich zu einem großteil im it sektor das heißt im endeffekt der bedarf an it fach
greffen ist nicht so dass das quasi gedeckt ist wenn jetzt irgendwie die die neue generation
azubis am start ist oder so das wird eher noch mehr werden die letzten jahre die nächsten
jahre und umso mehr stellen ersetzt werden durch technologie und das passiert jetzt schon
im großen umfeld und wenn die aktuelle generation an leuten in rente geht dann werden viele
jobs gehe ich stark von aus nicht wieder eins zu eins in dieser form existieren wie sie
jetzt existieren ich mein bergmänner ist wahrscheinlich bergfrauen oder bergbergsarbeiter sind wahrscheinlich
die letzte generation die sowas jetzt machen wird für immer in deutschland minenarbeiter
und es gibt noch andere bereiche da wird wahrscheinlich dass nie wieder das so geben wie es das jetzt
gibt wenn die in rente gehen und vieles wird eben durch technologie im weiteren sinn vielleicht
nicht eins zu eins dass es dann das gleiche gibt wie vorher und jetzt einfach paar roboter
am fließband stehen aber vieles wird zunehmend durch technologie ersetzt und das sorgt dafür
dass du in sehr vielen bereichen weniger leute brauchst aber gerade in der it und gerade
leute die auch ein bisschen ahnung von programmieren haben aber nicht nur programmieren aber generell
am t-bereich das steigt oder steigt ziemlich extrem noch die nächsten jahre gehe ich zumindest
von aus und da bin ich mal gespannt wie sie das machen wollen für uns ist das gut wir
können fette stonks machen ja ich meine du kannst jetzt schon mehr oder weniger aussuchen
wo du hingehst wenn du ein bisschen plan hast und dann hoffe ich dass es auch mal ordentlich
kohle gibt noch mehr ja also ich werde ich werde auf jeden fall nicht nein sagen
chain law bei google ja das will ich sehen ich will ich will dass chain law das nächste
youtube design macht dafür war der kurs voll mit mehls du meinst mein arbeitsamt kurs zu
der hälfte hälfte hälfte wobei die sache halt die waren die waren zum kostenteil mit
ihren männern bei diesem kurs das war eh lustig also von diesem kurs sagen wir mal
waren 50 prozent mehls und von diesen 50 prozent mehls waren mindestens 40 prozent waren
mindestens dann 80 prozent muss ich sagen weil das geht ja eingeschränkt war mindestens
80 prozent mit ihren männern da also ich habe quasi familienausflug zum werbe arbeitsamt
kurs gemacht und die waren auch alle schon schwanger oder hatten schon kinder mit keine
ahnung 19 18 manche hatten sogar schon manche waren 18 zwei kinder what the fuck ich verstehe
es nicht was da los war bei den leuten aber mich wundert auch nichts mehr ich habe ja
schon wie gesagt ich habe sogar schon zwei videos zu gemacht ich habe da auch schon viel
zu erzählt aber eines der einschneidsten aussagen die ich jemals und jetzt ohne übertreiben
zu wollen die ich jemals gehört habe in meinem leben war von einer auf diesem arbeitsamt
kurs und zwar die hat mir ernsthaft erzählt sie muss nicht lesen und schreiben können
warum weil ihr man das kann und da bin ich echt vom glauben abgefallen da habe ich mich
habt ich habe nicht glauben können dass sie das ernst meint lesen ist bloated das ist
die mit mit mit dem stecher genau das habe ich im video erzählt aber ernsthaft es geht
nicht um geige spielen lernen es geht um lesen und schreiben und die hat wirklich behauptet
das brauche ich nicht mein mann kann das da war es vorbei ich habe ich habe nicht gedacht
dass das so existiert auf dieser welt aber es ist so
ja das kenne ich noch also so ein bisschen so ein bisschen buchhaltung und bilanz kram
kann ich noch ich könnte sowas nicht mehr machen jetzt wenn einer sagt hier firma vor
aber so ein paar sachen würde ich wieder erkennen mehr nützliches gab es da nicht
nein nein in der fachinformatiker ausbildung hast du keine buchhaltung gemacht in der form
weiß eigentlich jemand was man als server admin oder system admin lernen muss das kann
man nicht pauschal sagen das hängt davon ab in welchem bereich du bist ich meine es
ist ja schon mal ganz offensichtlich bist du im windows bereich musst du windows administrieren
bist du im linux bereich musst du linux administrieren und es gibt bestimmt auch leute die administrieren
mac os aber von denen habe ich noch nie gehört aber bist du im windows bereich windows und
linux linux ja manche machen auch freebsd oder so dinge und alternativ was heute halt
immer noch viel also was was immer noch mehr zunimmt ist dass man sich mit cloud technik
technologien auskennen muss also dass der linuxserver bei euch vor ort läuft ist zunehmend
gerade bei kleinere denen zunehmend nicht mehr der fall das heißt du musst auch noch so
quasi nicht nur linux administrieren können sondern auch noch die cloud tools drum herum
verwenden können oder aber man entwickelt seine anwendung gleich so dass man gar keine
linux vm in der cloud mehr braucht sondern das mit wie sagt man so schön cloud native
sachen lösen kann es gibt auch arme säcke arme säcke die sich tatsächlich um telefonanlagen
kümmern müssen das ist richtig oder um cupanates cluster und solche dinger ja da hast du bestimmt
auch einiges gelernt mit gelernt meine ich jetzt nicht dass du sagen würdest auch meine
iku ist um zehn punkte gestiegen aber du weißt wie ich meine also erfahrung gemacht fürs
leben im endeffekt
so ich hoffe ich habe jetzt gleich geschafft ich bin irgendwann mit dem chat mal durch
der anderen seite ist schon fast schon schon spät ja so sieht es aus gute altilier werden
ohne ende gesucht es wird immer noch mehr in nächsten jahren ich sehe nicht dass das
abreißt es sei dann wir haben doch bald den dritten weltkrieg dann brauchst du auch noch
altiler aber wahrscheinlich brauchst du noch ein paar andere sachen wichtiger aber das
wollen wir nicht hoffen weil dann sinken meine stonks und ich habe jetzt so viel geld
in stonks gehauen weil ich keinen bock auf inflationen habe und jetzt fallen die stonks
auch noch also bei mir könnt ihr definitiv kein keine finanzanlage lernen keine anlageberatung
was ist das das kenne ich ja das ist das ist das wirst du irgendwann mal gucken das wirklich
gut das ist das ist auch dieser das ist auch dieser sketch mit eine rote linie malen die
sich nicht überschneiden aber sie sollen sich überschneiden oder irgendwie sowas und
er meint also das geht nicht oder doch doch machen sie das mal aber nur wenn ich noch
später angefangen hätte wäre noch schlechter also wir gucken heute wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr das facebook video und auch kein anderes großartig mehr weil es ist zu spät steht
ja schon im titel drin du hast ein spiel mit mqtt entwickeln wie wir entwickeln ein spiel
mit mqtt oder du meinst du hast ein spiel entwickelt was mqtt benutzt zum datenaustausch
du hast endlich deine it ausbildung sicher kratz hätte man da in mmos früher zugesagt
und die spanier hätten kratz mit z geschrieben habe mich vor einem halben jahr noch mit
bedenken bei dir gemeldet weil ich nix gefunden habe sekunde das müssen wir jetzt gleich
noch mal feiern moment falls das funktioniert mit stream mit mit mit twitch sekunde ich
werde euch jetzt nämlich mal vorlesen was er vor einem halben jahr geschrieben hat und
dann sagen wir poch wie gut das geklappt hat also hier du hast deine eines seiner letzten
nachrichten war mein max liegt max ist kiffer web nation alles klar ansonsten habe ich nix
dazu gefunden
so wir sind erst mal im holsthema also wie weit bin ich denn hinten dran mit dem chat
das war so schlimm wie bei semper video der ist auch immer zwei stunden hinten dran mit
dem chat in diesem video nur ganz kurz den chat durch scrollen damit wir keine schadwehr
bekommen wie alt ist der wie alt ist denn der sprecher
weiß man das der provider genau
das mag ich komischerweise nicht ja ich bin richtiger wim fanboy aber ich komme nicht
mit wim key bindings in anderen editors klar merkwürdig ich weiß nicht warum aber ein
editor der sich nicht anfühlt und aussieht wie wim wird auch nicht zu wim mit wim key
bindings
ich hab ein tool in dotnet programmiert welches im hintergrund als linux service daten verarbeitet
weil die benahmung von microsoft kacke ist
ich vermute mal gentlemen was deine frage ist wie bekomme ich informationen vom backend
ans frontend gepusht
ohne dass das frontend quasi permanent nachfragen muss ja also sprich wie kann ich mein frontend
updaten ohne dass ich die seite reloade auf auf deutsch ja auf gut deutsch das vermute
ich erst mal deine frage so da gibt es verschiedene varianten was du machen kannst die einfachste
ist wahrscheinlich und die dürfte wahrscheinlich auch praktikabel sein weil wenn du wirklich
nur einen wert refreshen willst nur ein paar bytes dann kannst du pollen set interval pollen
alle 200 millisekunden und gut ist das ist jetzt bestimmt nicht die hohe kunst und wahrscheinlich
sagen viele leute cringe max wer pollt denn sein backend aber wenn man sonst nix großartig
machen will und einfach nur ein paar bytes abfragen möchte dann kannst du einfach pollen
dann machst du ja was kipp set interval auf 200 millisekunden und fragst alle 200 oder
jede sekunde dann fragst du einfach alle 2 alle sekunde im backend nach ob das sich
geupdatet hat und wenn ja renderst du es neu ins frontend so die schönere variante und
neuere variante und und ja die die designtechnisch sauberere variante ist sowas wie websockets
zu verwenden das ist eine dauerhaft aufgebaute tcp verbindung wo dein backend zum frontend
updates pushen kann reactive du kannst auch sowas wie signal r verwenden das ist quasi
der offizielle websocken wrapper für asp.net core oder du kannst auch sowas wie craftql
subscriptions verwenden je nachdem was du da an daten übertragen musst es gibt da verschiedene
möglichkeiten wobei craftql subscriptions auch über websocket gehen du kannst auch grpc
verwenden es gibt ganz viele möglichkeiten aber ich vermute mal das einfachste ist für
dich du polst dein backend einmal in der sekunde und renderst wenn es was neues gibt oder aber
du machst websockets oder signal r mit asp.net core
er ist dead ja die wurden angepasst ja es gibt jetzt drei neue ausbildungsberufe zusätzlich
ja schick schick her wir haben wir haben wir noch genug zeit für schickt mal den lehrplan
her damit das wird das gucke ich das gucke ich mir gerne an gemm ich mal meinen senf
dazu vor allem wird mich mal interessieren wie das heute aussieht schreibt wupplos davor
dass ich gleich sehe wenn ich irgendwann den chat durchgescrollt habe
lowcode ist unser feind lowcode ist der größte hype also nein nicht der größte hype der
eines der auferhalb des dinger so der letzten des letzten jahres lowcode ist voll angesagt
und gerade irgendwelche bwl leute stehen da drauf vielleicht weil sie sich dann als krasse
programmierer fühlen können wenn sie wenn sie der meinung sind sie klicken in einem
web interface ein paar sachen zusammen und am ende haben sie dann google google spreadsheet
klonen oder so aber ganz im ernst niemand wird das nächste youtube in einer lowcode
platform programmieren oder sowas oder auch nur den den den label champ wird auch niemand
in low auf einer lowcode platform programmieren also das ist eher ich weiß nicht ich also
ich halte von der theorie nix dass wenn das demnächst jeder da hergelaufener bwl er programmieren
kann mit solchen tools und man keine programmierer braucht es ist eher das gegenteil wird wahrscheinlich
der fall sein habt ihr bei euch data science leute also ich glaube wir haben niemand der
das offiziell als titel hat wie siehst du den markt für fisi ohne kenntnisse ich sehe
den markt für leute ohne kenntnisse schlecht weil wenn du keine kenntnisse hast warum sollte
ich immer einstellen es sei denn du kannst damit punkten dass du sagst ich bin super
schnell mich im einarbeiten oder so und du bist dann auch schnell im einarbeiten das
ist eh das wichtigste ohne scheiß das wichtigste unterm schritt was ein fachinformatiker können
muss ist google bedienen und sich schnell einarbeiten können das sind die wichtigsten
fachinformatiker skills ach so schwerpunkt in programmieren aber ich hätte mal weiterlesen
sollen ich hätte mal weiterlesen soll ja das ist dann wieder was anderes dann hast
du ja dann hast du ja durchaus kenntnisse und dann hast du auch durchaus kenntnisse
die dich im fisi bereich weiterbringen weil niemand stellt ja einen fachinformatiker system
integration ein die stellen ja irgendwas ein wo sagen wir mal eine fachinformatiker system
ausbildung irgendwie gilt als ja du hast die richtige voraussetzung also sollte man
dann nachlegen oder reicht die reine administration ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau wie du wie
du das meinst also also grundsätzlich bin ich persönlich der meinung fachinformatiker
anwendungsentwicklung fachinformatiker system integration ist die letzten jahre schon zusammen
gewachsen thementechnisch gibt es immer mehr überschneidung und das wird auch noch weiter
zusammen wachsen gerade im hinblick dessen dass wenn man sich mal cloud platform anguckt
und da sowas wie cloud native na wie ist die abkürzung functions fast genau functions
as a service oder serverless geschichten hat da ist eine große überschneidung zwischen
anwendungsentwicklung und administration das kannst du gar nicht so klar zuordnen wo dort
die ja wo doch der fisi aufhört und da er anfängt ja oder wo da der programmierer aufhört
und der admin anfängt das kann man gar nicht mehr so so leicht sagen deswegen gerade in
so einem bereich ist super wenn du programmier erfahrung hast ja auch im deffops bereich
wenn du sagst ok ich mache jetzt zwar nicht mehr 90 prozententwicklung am tag aber ich
kümmere mich beispielsweise um tools für programmieren für um tools für programmierer
sei es irgendeine ci pipeline oder irgendwelches deployment gedöns oder sei es auch dass es
automatische jobs gibt die bei einem git push was machen und solche geschichten da ist wunderbar
wenn du weißt wie man sachen programmiert und ich auch ein bisschen rein denken kannst
wie programmierer arbeiten ja es ist dass es in dem bereich tatsächlich besser als
irgendeiner der der meinung ist und das ist im admin bereich lasst euch das mal gesagt
sein dass es im admin bereich relativ verbreitet was ich jetzt sagen werde viele admins sind
der meinung programmierer sind unfähig also programmierer schaffen nicht die einfachsten
dinger zu programmieren dabei ist es doch ganz offensichtlich was da gemacht werden
muss das ist aber immer so das ist so was in diese falle tappt man relativ schnell weil
man immer denkt die anderen sind blöd und können die einfachsten sachen nicht ja ich
habe beispielsweise bei uns leute schon sagen hören und mit vollster überzeugung wir haben
beispielsweise ein team was sich drum kümmt was sich drum kümmert dass unsere ganzen
java anwendungen gebaut werden patches kriegen deployed werden updates deployed werden sowas
in der richtung sie kümmern sich im prinzip nur ums ausrollen neuer software versionen
was dann letztendlich auch unsere endkunden verwenden und ich habe leute bei uns schon
sagen gehört dieses ganze team braucht niemand das ersetzen wir durch den bash script und
das meinte der wirklich 100 prozentig ernst natürlich gibt es dort leute die keinen plan
haben es gibt aber auch im system administrationsteam im dev ops team in entwickerteams immer leute
die keinen plan haben das ist jetzt nicht das was man als maßstab anlegen sollte ich
würde sogar sagen dass 50 prozent der leute eigentlich gefühlt keine ahnung haben das
würde ich jetzt aber nicht sagen ja nur bei mir haben die leute ahnung überall anders
nicht das ist halt durch die bank weg so ja 90 prozent der menschheit ist halt nun mal
planlos ich auch in sehr vielen bereichen und deswegen ist das eine super sache wenn
du programmieren kannst gerade gerade im dev ops bereich und gerade wenn es um entwickler
tools geht oder um deployment oder continuous integration delivery und solche geschichten
oder eben halt auch um einrichten von von irgendwelchen umgebungen environments im cloud
umfeld oder wenn du function deployments macht da ist das wichtig dass man ein bisschen programmieren
kann also ich denke schon dass du da was findest je nachdem was halt ne also wenn du keine ahnung
vor administrieren hast wird es natürlich schwierig wenn du jetzt nicht auf ihren hardcore
linux job bewirbst ja also wenn drinne steht so nach dem motto ihre zweite muttersprache
ist engine x konfig weiß nicht ob es stellenanzeigen gibt wo sowas drin steht dann ist natürlich
schwierig zu sagen ja ich bewert mich damals eben als anwendungsentwickler drauf aber ansonsten
möchte ich dir ja kein problem
irgendwo da erzähle ich von einer projektarbeit für die ich eine eins bekommen habe was könntest
du die mal vom konzept der bewerten welche projektarbeit dein dein mqtt game oder oder
was ich bin so weit im chat hinterher ich weiß nicht um was es geht mehr ich glaube
gleich habe ich nächstes jahr abi jetzt schon eine stelle suchen und noch ein jahr warten
wo soll ich das wissen wenn du den karriere crime möglichst früh starten willst denn
jetzt schon stelle suchen ich persönlich war in deinem alter faul as fuck und hätte mir
garantiert keine stelle gesucht ich hätte lieber mmo kreisel kind gemacht was jetzt
aber keiner der karriere advice ist ihr solltet generell eine sache in eure bewerbung reinschreiben
ich schaue max fps auf youtube und ich habe wupp loss auf twitch abonniert ob es stimmt
oder nicht ist egal kommt immer gut an und dann beendet ihr dann beendet ihr das vorstellungsgespräch
mit wann zeigt die sylvaner endlich ihre brüste das versteht wahrscheinlich auch niemand mehr
der nicht damals dabei war die dachten sich sie wollen ihre statistik verbessern und nicht
mich gut beraten ok ich nähe ich nähe mich dem unteren ende vom chat ich habs ich habs
im gefühl hier ja wir sind schon beim web nation span spam du bist bei semper video gebannt ich
irgendwie kann ich mich sogar wirklich ich kann es mir vorstellen ja der channel ist da
reingekommen hat irgendwelche blöden dinger gespammt und das fand man dort nicht lustig
und hatte gekickt das kann ich mir gut vorstellen der channel hat bestimmt salami gespammt oder
sowas ja das kann ich mir vorstellen dass das passt in das passt ins bild wie man so
schon sagt ja du bist nicht zu spät noch zwei minuten hier der link zum leerplan ok
wow what the fuck was sehe ich da überhaupt referat für bildung und sport sport block
plan ja und versteht jetzt da was man macht da steht doch gar nichts ich habe keine ahnung
was jgst ist er hat es nochmal geschickt echt wo
ja es ist ist halt ist halt so ja wo hat es dann nochmal geschickt
hier so nach ruby fern ruby ja bin ich ruby ist pock lernfelder in der berufsschule 11123
ist ich also weg damit weg
hier ist der richtige leerplan ok also erstes ausbildungsjahr 12 wochen bgp das unternehmen
und die eigene rolle im betrieb 111 das hatten wir auch da kann ich mich dran da kann ich
mich noch dran erinnern arbeitsplätze nach kundenwunsch ausstatten moment das hatten
wir nicht lernt man da wie man den rechner aufbaut sehe ich das richtig also so quasi
eines der unbedeutendsten sachen und immer unbedeutend werden werden deren skills ok
meinetwegen kleinste netzwerke einbinden ok hatten wir wahrscheinlich auch hieß aber
anders schutz bedarfanalyse im eigenen arbeitsbereich durchführen kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern
dass wir das gemacht haben angebote für monitore einholen das ist quasi der bw l teil das hat
das haben wir in in in in es könnte vielleicht sogar wirklich lf 2 gewesen sein das haben
wir unter anderem gemacht dort wo der lehrer über mein ds ladekabel gestolpert ist es
war bw l krempe deutsch englisch politik und das hatten wir ja das hatten wir auch
sport hatten wir auch religio etik ja ok wir hatten wir auch also wir hatten sowohl
etik die lehrerin war nicht da die lehrerin war nicht da wir haben dann am ende alle eine
zweier gekriegt wo war ich war immer so viele zuschauer mich jemand gehostet was ich übersehen
habe was denn jetzt los monkeys habe ich habe ich den haust übersehen wenn der chain law
schreibt ja glaube ich ihm das nicht weil der tschibetet immer habe ich irgendwas übersehen
serius max hat abonniert dann habe ich nicht gesehen nö wurde nicht groß dann nice dass
so viele leute da sind ich bin übrigens nicht mal lange da nur nur so angemerkt aber schön
dass ihr alle da seid 500 was zum teufel krieg ich auf einmal so viele zuschauer welche
viewportet oder was und jetzt und jetzt muss ich weg das auch geil oder leute ist mein ist mein ist
mein twitch ist meine twitch anzeige kaputt warum sind auf einmal auf einen schlag so viele leute
da nee ok meine twitch anzeige ist kaputt ich habe nichts gesagt 286 gut nice bin ich ja beruhigt
dass ich jetzt nicht abhauen wer abhauen werden auf einmal 500 leute am start sind
keine ahnung was das gewesen ist ja 491 denn es bei mir auch gerade
what the fuck leute leute wo kommt ihr alle her wo kommt ihr alle her auf einmal sagt
mal habe ich habe ich in den haus übersehen wo kommt ihr alle her
huge huge streamer hat immer den hat immer den viewport gekauft oder was ich meine es
kam oft genug schon leute die sich irgendwelche china chinesen dedos sachen gekauft haben warum
sollte sich nicht einer viewport kaufen aber schön dass ihr alle da seid ich muss euch leider
enttäuscht wo immer ihr herkommt sorry falls ich den host übersehen habe bei mir steht nichts da
schön dass ihr alle da seid dass ihr den weg gefunden habt hierher ich muss leider bald schon
oft ich bin alt ich bin 37 und ich muss regelmäßig um 22 ins bett weil ansonsten mache ich das in
meinem alter nicht halte ich das nicht aus so und es ist schon spät dementsprechend muss ich bald
abhauen aber ich sollte mir noch mal die aktuellen lernfelder vom fachinformatik angucken also zeigt
mal her wo sind verstehen geblieben und das hatten wir auch politik und gesellschaft
und 524 leute wo kommt ihr alle her wenn ich wenn ich seriously gerade die viewport oder sowas
normalerweise habe ich irgendwie ja keine ahnung 300 in der spitze oder so wenn ich eine weile
ungewesen bin aber 594 wenn ich auch noch gerade den aktuellen lehrplan für fachinformatik auf
haben den auch nicht viele interessiert keine ahnung ein haufen eland subscribe dankeschön
für den sub unter profil list ist auch am start danke für den primes ab was zum teufel keine
ahnung ok zeig mal kurz her service anfragen bearbeiten so und die service anfragen das hatten
wir nicht das hatte ich nicht in der berufsschule service anfragen beantworten er bearbeiten klingt
für mich ein bisschen wie du musst hotline sachen machen ich hoffe nicht dass die dass die mit den
leuten üben hotline sachen zu machen weil sie wirklich hotline ist eines der beschissen sachen
die du machen kannst also first level support hotline und solche sachen ich würde es selbst
für das verbinden also ich würde es wahrscheinlich für das doppelte von dem was ich jetzt verdiene
nicht machen hotline ist das schlimmste was es gibt cyber physische systeme ergänzen ok also
wer diesen namen also wer das benahmt hat verstehe ich nicht was soll das was soll das sein cyber
physische systeme da hat sich irgend da hat sich irgendwie also als super high IQ 5 header bei
der ihk gedacht das klingt alles so alt backen wir nennen das jetzt cyber physische systeme
ergänzen keiner weiß keine sau weiß was es sein soll aber dabei also zeigt mal hier was ist es
denn was ist denn cyber physische systeme cyber cyber physische der name ist so hängen geblieben
ok cyber physische systeme ergänzen automatisierungs pyramide industrie 4.0 iot was genau hat das jetzt
mit cyber und ok was auch immer cps bestandteil verfahren sensoren aktoren mittel wehrm qt a das
ist quasi so ein bisschen was in richtung heim automatisierung klingt zumindest so finde ich cool
dass so was in der berufsschule mal thema ist stich stelle fällt busse programmier konzepte
programmier sprachen idee sicherheitsinformationen knx smart home das finde ich cool dass das
einzug in den leerplan erhält erhalten hat das ist cool aber es ist ein absoluter bullshit name
cyber physische systeme ergänzen ernsthaft also wenn sich das bei der ik überlegt hat
den sollten sie sich besser keine namen mehr ausdenken lassen ja ich beschwer mich über
den namen der name ist kacke von industrie ich glaube wir sind mittlerweile schon bei industrie
5.0 und web 8.0 oder so so datensystem übergreifen bereitstellen das hatten wir glaube ich auch aber
es hieß anders 11 8 aber das hatten wir glaube ich auch was ist denn das da vorne itt 11 6 7
warum heißt das einmal so und dann so also bei uns die bau uns hieß der kram auch 11 ok jetzt
bin ich wieder bei normalen zuschauergrößen ich glaube twitch hat einfach nur rumgebackt aber
trotzdem schön dass ihr da gewesen seid nicht vorhandene 200 zuschauer sport gibt's wieder
religion na gut so das ist dann der unterschied zwischen den ganzen e geht wertschöpfungs
prozesse ergebnis orientiert monka es das ist bewl shit immer plus auf ja aber da sieht man
auch so ein riesen unterschied ist jetzt da gar nicht mehr dazwischen ja aber so viel hat sich
da nicht geändert also ich kann dir plus sagen zum thema berufsschule ich persönlich fand die
berufsschule nicht ok ich muss überlegen wie ich das sage ich bin immer gerne in die berufsschule
gegangen aber die berufsschule an sich war nicht sinnvoll was man da gelernt hat also die berufsschule
war zum größten teil grotten schlecht auch von den lehrern her auch vom tempo her es war im
endeffekt absolut schnecken tempo in allem gerade in programmieren das war komplett komplett
unsinnig also wir haben da im dritten jahr noch wie schreibe ich eine funktion gemacht und leute
haben sünder nicht ohne sonntagsfehler hinbekommen aber berufsschule ist easy berufsschule ist im
prinzip ihr habt urlaub berufsschule ist nicht zum lernen dafür was denn sonst also fragt mal
jemand von der iak für was die berufsschule gedacht ist was sie dir sagen dass es praktisch
gesehen im prinzip däumchen drehen und urlaub machen es ist was anderes aber offiziell ist
sie selbstverständlich zum inhalte vermitteln da praktisch nicht richtig so sieht es aus
zumindest je nachdem unter welchem betriebssystem du unterwegs bist wenn du unter windows bist ein
bisschen power shell solltest du können mit mit batch und cmd wer das heute macht in dem
ist nicht mehr zu der ist nicht mehr zu retten und unter linux solltest du selbstverständlich auch ein
bisschen bash können bash scripting ist immer wichtig selbst wenn man andere scripting lösungen
kann bash ist oftmals einfach kurz und knackig und hilft einem auch im täglichen täglichen admin
leben ja dass man mal eine vorschleife in der bash machen kann dass man ein paar text sachen
rausfiltern kann dass man sort unique machen kann krepp was zählen kann also bash scripting sollte
sich jeder admin der auch nur entfernt ein bisschen was mit linux zu tun hat angucken und nachdem es
heute wsl gibt und dementsprechend linux auch unter windows ordentlich läuft sollte sich das auch
jeder windows admin mal angeguckt haben aber dann viel erfolg max karriere consulting heute ich
wurde schon gefragt per mail ob ich also ich habe schon anfragen per mail bekommen ob ich
ihre stellenangebote bewerten könnte und sowas wahrscheinlich weil ich so viele stellenanzeigen
review videos gemacht habe und einem einer hat auch gar also ich habe ich habe ich habe geantwortet
drauf und einer hat dann zurückgeschrieben cool danke für die antwort max ich wollte dem eigentlich
verkaufen dass sie mich gerne für eine ausführlichere antwort bezahlen können aber das wollten sie
dann nicht darauf einigen ich habe gedacht wenn ich sowas schon mache quasi kostenlos da kann ich
auch ein bisschen geld für mich rausschlagen aber es hat nicht funktioniert aber hat geantwortet
danke danke für die für die antwort und für deine mühen stellen wir dir gerne ein weiß ich was
er geschrieben hat ein ein ein goody pack zur verfügung da hätte ich dann quasi ein t-shirt
bekommen von der jeweiligen firma mit ihrem logo drauf habe ich mir gedacht naja nee das
brauche ich nicht unbedingt war ich nicht so scharf drauf so sieht es aus
was war nicht ein plan ich habe den zusammenhang komplett aus aus dem zusammenhang gerissen
gewesen gelesen im chat so ich glaube ich habe es fast geschafft ich muss unbedingt mehr sellout
machen guck mal es gibt leute die machen streams wo sie sich beim schlafen filmen und sowas und mit
irgendwelchen krassen subgoals und sonst was und ich mache nicht einmal ich habe die letzten ich
glaube ich habe die letzten fünf streams einen sub sellout gemacht es gibt andere die haben
das schon so automatisiert die hauen die die hauen die krassesten überleitung krassesten
sub sellouts raus im stunden takt ja ich habe das einfach noch nicht so sehr in meinen workflow
integriert den sub sellout nicht desto trotz wenn ihr einen freien prime sub habt wie zum
beispiel ein haufen elend und ich wüsste wohin damit ich freue mich über jeden prime sub und
ich freue mich aber auch über jeden der da ist und hier zuguckt und vor allem der sich auch aktiv
im chat beteiligt weil wenn ich mich einfach nur abends hinsetze was ich ja manchmal mache
und sinnlos vor mich hin laber das geht nicht ohne aktiven chat weil oder zumindest will ich
nicht den ganzen abend videos gucken deswegen bin ich froh dass so viele leute da sind so viele
regelmäßig auch am start sind ich ganz viele leute hier ohne scheiß wenn ich hier durchscrolle
ich kenne euch alle vom namen her irgendwie ein bisschen ok ok übertrieben nicht alle aber
90 prozent der leute die ich hier durchscrolle kenne ich vom namen her schon vom sehen was
halt wirklich nice ist dass so viele leute immer wieder da sind auch wenn ich mir mal
nix für den stream überlegt habe und einfach nur einschalte
dankeschön für den sub wolle poc subscriptions ach du hast gegiftet ja trotzdem dankeschön
für den gift sub wir hatten glück gehabt der collaborative rocker hat glück gehabt
ja pauli ich kann dich jeden einzeln vorlesen würdest du prime subscriben dann würde ich
dich natürlich vorlesen weil ich mich dann ja für den prime sub bedanken müsste aber
ansonsten kann ich schlecht jeden einzelne ansprechen trotzdem finde ich schön dass
so viele da sind eine umfrage vorschlagen keck weh beste umfrage wie wäre es mal wenn
man was mit kanalpunkten machen könnte ja da gibt es leider nicht so viele möglichkeiten
was man machen kann ich könnte irgendwelche sachen einführen die ich da nicht mache weil
sie mir auf den keks gehen ja zum beispiel irgendwelche voice nachrichten die vorgelesen
werden wo dann der chain law permanent irgendwie oder sowas drinne spamt und es in den text
to speech vorliest oder oder ich könnte irgendwelche anderen sachen machen aber ich mache es wahrscheinlich
im endeffekt wieder aus ehrlich wenn ihr gute ideen habt für sub points die ja auch zu passen
ohne scheiß ich bin nicht abgeneigt sub points zu machen also was man ausgeben kann aber
mir fällt da nicht so viel ein und ich will auch keinen motor der meinen stuhl steuert
oder so komische dinger ja jv peak der hat total viel abgedrehtes zeug was man machen
kann wenn man webcams hat und wenn man generell auf so abgedrehtes zeug steht teo danke für
den zapp der hat aber eh schon richtig ich habe bei dem auch schon ab und zu geguckt
da schon richtig cooles zeug ja auch sein pokemon zeug wo er leute fangen kann die
in hausten und sowas also der macht sich da schon gedanken
ach nina hat coole hat coolen stuff für channel points das stimmt da habe ich schon ab und
zu mal reingeguckt da kann ich aber nicht lange reingucken weil ich dann quasi wie soll
ich sagen herzrhythmusstörung bekomme weil ich mein ach nina die hat ahnung von technik
hat plan kann arduino zeug programmieren sieht auch noch mega hübsch aus das kann ich nicht
lange angucken dass das halte ich nicht aus das alles in kombination ist zu viel für
mich jetzt jetzt jetzt reißt euch zusammen reißt euch zusammen was ist hier los nicht
auf die art wie ihr das im chat schreibt reißt euch zusammen spam blieb so komisches zeug
wie der chainlord du kommst öfters vorbei das sieht schön aus freut mich hast du mal
eine neue story über die db und dem 9 euro ticket ne gerade nicht ich bin mit dem 9 euro
noch nicht gefahren mit asmr stream für kanalpunkte wenn ich überlege ich würde ok überlegt
mal wahrgenommen ich würde asmr content machen ich glaube nicht dass ich das gut könnte
da müsste ich dann zum beispiel da müsste ich dann zum beispiel irgendwas flüstern
in form von ich kann gar nicht flüstern weil ich habe mein neues geht an da hört man
glaube ich gar nichts und die ganzen die kenne die ganzen asmr grills die immer so rumschmatzen
so nach dem motto ich lecke dein ohr ab und sowas das finde ich übelst pervers oder was
heißt pervers übelst abartig das muss los ja ist es auch da verstehe ich nicht warum
die leute das gucken tastatur asmr ich brauche auch so ich würde euch dann auch so ein oren
mikrofon ja genau wobei diese oren mikrofone eigentlich total overrated sind ich finde
es tatsächlich besser wenn die leute zwei ordentliche mikrofone stehen haben den einen
die ein oder anderen asmr videos gucke ich auch aber ich bin jetzt kein 24 7 asmr konsument
ja teo danke für den zapp ja chat wie sie wieder ausgeflippt sind das war schnell drüberscrollen
der chat wieder everett donator nummer number one na klar jetzt fehlt bloß noch pokey v
virgin check im chat was ist was ich was ich denke sie eigentlich aus in die fox geworden
ist sie wieder entband oder ist sie endgültig fort ob dies endgültig fort ja von von twitch
oder wisst ihr was das schlimme ist ich guck das ja nicht aber irgendwie so ein paar namen
kennt man trotzdem nein bloß nicht the fuck ich sollte sowas nicht im stream erzählen
da werde ich dann habe ich passende emot für ich habe ich habe kein emot wo jemand rot
wird oder so brauche ich normalerweise auch nicht also leute es ist spät es ist 22 23
ich gehe jetzt pennen ja emot a chat auf nähe ist kein video mehr drin das ist ich müsste
eigentlich schon um 23 vor 23 minuten 23 minuten weg add it tatsächlich das finde ich das
finde ich gar nicht übel das kann ich tatsächlich ich habe noch so viel ja aber zum thema emots
ich habe glaube ich mittlerweile zehn emot slots oder oder noch mehr ich glaube ich
habe wenn man die premium emots also die die tier tier 2 und sonst was immer ich glaube
ich habe sogar noch mehr frei ich muss mir wirklich unbedingt mal neue emots design lassen
wieder immerhin wir haben schon mega cool aber ich brauche noch unbedingt mehr und ich habe
eine riesen in der riesen liste mit emots also leute alles klar wir sehen uns im nächsten
stream bis denn macht's gut ich gehe jetzt auf zu